une production du studio sfr est venu
sans filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos invités date site jph
campait avec moi tomb of doom planque
cette semaine on aurait su marie ève
nault qui astrophysicienne et
vulgarisatrice scientifique c'était
juste avant un petit mot de noces
pentures le batka d'aujourd'hui est
présenté par fs a eu la balle
encore une fois la faculté des sciences
rémunération de lui verser la balle si
vous voulez combler un manque dans vos
compétences en gestion c'est la
meilleure manière et des programmes
diplômants que vous pouvez faire des
bacs d'une maîtrise mbiye toute l'équipe
et aussi des formations plus courtes sud
est déjà un travail à temps partiel vous
êtes travailleur autonome et voulait
juste parfait recettes certaines notions
les chercher quelques outils c'est
vraiment une bonne façon et des
formations qui sont 100 % à distance
sont montés pour être à distance par
interactive super optimisé
c'est vraiment cool cours puis vous êtes
obligés d'être entreprenants que vous
soyez mettons scientifique où que vous
soyez peu importe quoi à votre compte
vous allez avoir besoin de gérer des
gens vous allez avoir besoin de gérer
des budgets donc fsu laval offre une
quantité de microprogramme pour aller
chercher je cite spécifications là comme
par exemple le microprogramme en
développement des compétences
entrepreneuriales microprogramme en
gestion de projet microprogramme en
management puis si vous savez pas
exactement ce2 qu'est-ce que vous avez
besoin
mais lyon une équipe chevronnée qui vont
être capables de vous diriger vers un
programme pour vous pour aller chercher
juste le petit exploit menteur
à votre qualité de gestionnaire donc si
vous voulez plus d'information on va
mettre le lien dans la décision du
podcast by juste sur une note plus
personnelle et universelle a valsé notre
université à nous c'est à québec qui
pisse et de la faune ses formes ses
fonds fait qu'ils aient merci oui le
podcast de cette semaine et présenté par
auch la gauche lag c'est notre
fournisseur officiel d'alcool au studio
c'est une distillerie une
microbrasseries québécoises qui font des
produits qui se distinguent par leur
qualité comme en témoignent ses deux
jeans si le jean à l'hibiscus qui est
rose qui est complètement une scène le
jean dans de lyon qui est tout aussi
croesi à nous on trippe sur leurs
produits dans l'aude c'est notre oui on
a plein de sortes de bières prennent
soin d'eux ici on aime jean tony kelly
déjà brassé des tendances à cannes est
tout ce boudin d'une technique pas trop
sucré vraiment délicieux pour le palais
plein de sortes de bières différentes
rossi a épié blanche fait avec des
miches de pain
la plupart des bières brassées des
ingrédients 100% québécois donc on parle
d'acheter local c'est vraiment une bonne
manière d'encourager plus moche vraiment
content qu'on ait leur produit au studio
parce que c'est dans mes produits
québécois alcoolisée préférée
ouais puis ont tellement un éventail de
produits qui est large qu'on peut
quand qu'on peut pas cette année dont
les arts on en a beaucoup ici le sait
pas aujourd'hui une petite rousse james
sims et gento où j'aime belge into loin
c'est lars eller gamme prêt à bord ça
facilite vraiment la ville comme des
musées tantôt et merci à chlef pour
votre support en continu du sans-fil
podcast 10,6 à l'église donc cette
semaine marie ève nault sur le podcast
où on explore les confins de l'univers
moi c'était chez les 10 pires je les
attaque a fait aussi une des choses que
je voulais parler sous pas de cage et à
écouter les podcasts d'astrophysique des
packages scientifique [ __ ] et les
cheveux je collabore ces sujets là parce
que souvent je me couche le soir en
disant sur le cosmos avançons l'univers
par les ans les lois de la physique la
physique quantique pis chic à petit je
dois bien dire non mais vraiment je
trouve que ça nous rappelle notre place
dans l'univers nous rappelle sa touche
auquel son existence yeux c'est vraiment
fascinant c'est vrai tout à fait puisque
conversation qui l'est tout autant fait
que abonnez vous à nos chaînes
participer à la conversation les seniors
puis surtout surtout profité de ce qu'il
verse à son hobby même si on est
minuscule ou microscopique dans
l'univers
on est aussi important il cède la vie
dans l'univers
vous le découvrirez en ce votre caste
[Musique]
ça roule ça lui allô allô merci d'être
là on est vraiment contents ça fait
longtemps qu'on compare de recevoir
quelqu'un qui connaît l'espace univers
puis je pense combine phone
je reste vraiment ben mabrouk est lisse
depuis le début de parler de ce qu'on
s'apprête à parler ça fait deux ans et
demi qu'on fait pas de castellet a enfin
on va en parler d'hommes tous été avec
se tenir de grosse taille sont vraiment
marqué dans la science mais justement on
s'est parlé au téléphone marie-eve que
je t'avais du celtic c'est vraiment bête
oncle je pense ça fait cinq ans que
j'écoutais ce la série cosmos
ce sont des filles comptant maintenant
ils puissent on est triste
puis j'ai vraiment le j'ai vraiment
panier de quoi je vais te qu'il s'est
vraiment fascinante et la science en
général l'astrophysique principe tu es
vraiment principalement qu'il apprécie
viry foulée puis j'ai commencé quand tu
écris pas de cassettes vidéo possibles
imaginables le fait qu'il faut que je
teste le teint mais qu'acheter
qu'acheter kid j'avais su je me souviens
il ya une période de ma vie qui
achetaient enfin qu' on me demandait qui
se voulait faire plutôt que je disais à
se trouve si si même pas ce tronçon
physicien puis quoi oui mais ça ne
s'apprend pas parce qu'elle était une
zone où on fait une émission pour les
enfants de 3 à 8 ans c'est incroyable la
réponse qu'on a assez on est vraiment
sûr agréablement surprise
mais après chacun mais c'est pas si
surprenant que ça non plus et il ya ces
allées l'espace les dinosaures étaient
jeudi ya quand même un nombre de sujets
tous les animaux de la ferme
toutes les séries de lui vont parler à
un moment donné d'espacé je pense que
c'est un sujet que comme tout le monde
et on peut intéresser de près ou de loin
mais des fois on déconnecte un beurre de
notre passion d'enfant parce qu'on se
dira psychosociaux c'est de la physique
où ça c'est dit matt aussi c'est
compliqué où ben ainslie scientifique
qui s'occupe de tout petits mangent peu
scientifique
mais comme moi présentement c'est
vraiment genre mon objectif numéro 1
professionnelle que tout le monde sache
que les premiers mois besoin d'être un
scientifique pourtant intéresser à ce
qui ce fait en sciences le sais parce
que je passe pas mal d'énergie a
communiqué la science d'une manière que
j'espère accessible et je sais que j'ai
encore beaucoup m'améliorer je cherche à
améliorer tout le temps d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup de m'inviter parce que je sais
qu'aujourd'hui je vais peut-être à des
gentils moutons et coutrier paul la
série cote cosmo ajouté irait pas voir
naturellement va écouter des ans et que
je trouve ça vraiment cool puis je
trouve ça important c'est que tu es même
genre j'ai pas les jeunes noté à qui on
parle parce qu'on parle à des jeunes de
tous les âges
il y en a qui vont devenir des
scientifiques tant mieux et on parle
souvent d'astronomie comme le gateway
sayan ce genre là la science porte
d'entrée donc beaucoup de scientifiques
qui ont commencé à s'intéresser aux
sciences avec une passion pour
l'astronomie c'est on dirait que c'est
comme je sais pas si je sais pas si
c'est plus attractif où c'est plus sexy
comme science partir du maquereau
rendrait jeu basket quoi de justement
d'une verse universellement fascinant
avec les spurs et surtout t on dit les
enfants sont philosophes les enfants
posent des questions sur tout c'est quoi
c'est pourquoi si on en a qui le cosmos
pose ces questions loti d'ouest convient
est-ce qu'on est seul dans l'univers
pourquoi qu'on ait le tout soutenu ses
rangs des questions fondamentales tipi
témoin mettons au cégep justement j'ai
eu un autre coup de compassion pour
mettons la philo ti qui pose un peu les
mêmes questions que la physique
crânement tiny que les méthodes pour
trouver la réponse sont différentes mais
c'est toujours la même question tu
essaie de garder ces questions-là
activement que je trouve super
intéressant pour les jeunes parce que
les jeunes filles en ont des bonnes
questions le synchro et able to the swan
liste des questions infini le genre
petite alice cinq ans sa demande qu'est
ce qu'il y à a
au dessus de l'univers
puis je pense qu'on continence les
pauses riz après franchement c'est juste
qu'à un moment donné comme je poserai
pas question le quoi mais on va mener
aux jeux parce qu'on se fait ensuite
filé à deux mètres ce côté là de notre
nous retenons penser nos questionnements
de côté l'impression que l'on devienne
adulte c'est comment on pose pas ces
questions le magnifique et la vie
finalement c'est comme faire mon petit
chemin dans le monde réel mais que tout
l'univers l'oubli n'était pas meetic moi
quand j'étais jeune le tester il y en a
toujours le déclasser un petit exposé à
des millions de questions une petite
pause est mis en question qu'ils
arrêtent de paul que ce soit c'est moi
c'est moi mais j'ai eu des profs qui ont
encouragé ceux du monde sait qui m'ont
soutenu qui m'ont alimenter le thé la
veine preuve que j'ai fait j'avais comme
finis mes cahiers le en 5e année à noël
et à nous inscrire pour jouer dans une
pièce de théâtre au théâtre l'aborder à
québec je jouais dans une vraie pièce de
théâtre cinquième année je manquais une
avant midi sur dur pendant toute la
période où un métier dont canada des
profs c'est qui qui réalise qu'il ya des
enfants sera l'unique qui nourrissent
mais je me suis aussi souvent fait dire
marié va imposer que cette liste aix à
gauche et puis je suis coupable de le
faire dès fois avec mon propre fils qui
va voir si ça le cje comme mais il fait
des recherches pour les podcasts et j'ai
sorti mon gros livre les planètes se
sent un bol est nul ça vous tente
d'acheter c'est aux éditions multimondes
rimbaud l'ifp j'ai regardé les pages que
le manga mais pourquoi mais ce yoyo
autant de missions que s'est il montré
genre toutes les missions que lui vers
mars toutes les missions qu'il va vite
les mystères qui a eu peur parce que
paye
c'était fini ces questions l'iphone
secours et répondent à toutes les
questions pas mal et arriverait au bout
de mais pourquoi il ya de la vie plutôt
canaux populaire va avec
pourtant dans fil hôtels au cégep en
philo au pit et j'avais un prof qui est
commun il faut absolument que tu ailles
en philosophie puis jetée comme moi ben
j'aime sortir et réfléchir mais on
dirait que j'ai plus l'impression de
répondre à mes questions
quand je suis du côté de la physique
même si bon pendant mes études en
physique parce que j'ai fait un bac en
physique le pour donner une
astrophysicienne ou astronomes je me
livre mais nous sommes jeudi tout a
frustré et je fais comme si tu vraiment
ça la réponse devrait ainsi tomber
compliqué et si tu vraiment ta meilleure
explication pour ce parce que je
comprends pas plus que tantôt que si je
trouvais j'ai trouvé ça un petit peu
frustrant par bout parce que j'avais
l'impression que gérer comme les
réponses si tu parlais de grandes
questions
ben je sais pas me semble que je les ai
pas trouvés temps accepté justement à
travers des le travail des gens comme
neil degrasse tyson ou quand ses gains
avant lui parce que c'est la fameuse
série cosmos c'est comme un remake
reboot au aimé la série cosmos avec or
segan vous irez voir si je pense une
femme sur youtube il le faisait quand
même c'est vraiment épique
c'est toute ma vie je vais me regarder
celle ci campe un foyer c'est donc un
extraordinaire l'univers si ce mois que
j'aimerais que tout le monde semblait
les jeunes les vieux
peu importe c'est quoi ta formation ton
parcours ton profil c'est que genre les
bottines l'univers ils appartiennent à
tout le monde
si vous tapez pas besoin d'avoir des
grosses matt avancé pour triper en
apprenant genre que les étoiles est mort
dans des explosions spectaculaires qui
en plus d'un des images vraiment belle
je sais pas que des exoplanètes qui
convient juste qu'elle ment de
l'apprendre
on vient de le confirmer en fait c'est
tout y est tellement tellement tellement
genre de deux merveilles ça sonne un peu
cheap
il y en a vraiment beaucoup plus
moi des fois je trouve surtout
présentement en pleine pandémie
mon travail je l'aimais des jeux je
l'aimé mais là je l'adoré parce que ça
me permet de déconnecter puis de
reconnecter avec cette espèce de petite
magie le thé cette espèce de grandeur de
l'univers de crime c'est vraiment je
sais pas si grâce et ses vastes c'est
merveilleux puis nous on est important
on est comme spéciaux dans ce sens parce
que ça c'est aussi quelque chose que tu
réalises quand tu étudies
l'astrophysique les exoplanètes quand je
m'intéresse à la recherche de vie
ailleurs dit ne pas trouver un comme
david ont élu ce fait éclater comme
c'est ça fait pas longtemps il ya plein
de raisons qui peuvent expliquer comme
nous retrouvons encore mais qu'en même
temps dit il y en a pas partout le thé
c'est pas genre on a commencé à chercher
il y en avait le fait que diakite
quelque chose de spécial puis ça fait
réfléchir
mais son direction c'est que tu peux le
prendre des deux côtés au site c'est
quand même quelqu'un moi je m'intéresse
pas absolument à l'astrophysique qui
tiennent à tout cela mais mettons
qu'injuste quand j'en parle avec dom
excusez moi pis que je réalise mettons
l'étendue de l'univers ont déjà eu dans
ma tête ça complique pas quel point on
n'est pas vraiment spécial dans le fond
le titre c'est comme si des deux côtés
si oui elle est spéciale parce qu'on n'a
pas trouvé mais en même temps qu'à qu'on
dit mettons ça prend j'ai pas de 12000
amené sera le plus loin que nous on
écarte de voir quand on sait que c'est
loin d'être le plus loin qu'on va
regarder le fond de l'océan quand tu
vois pas le bout tu le sais un peu
l'histoire mettant de la science ou de
l'astronomie stress et de se rendre
compte à quel point dans l on n'est pas
dans le centre de l'île bars et salons
c'est super bon conseil appelé
d'après le principe de médiocrité dans
le sens que l'on n'est pas spécial qui a
été comme un gros choc là un moment
donné de réaliser qu'à la terre était
pas au centre de l'univers
mais les gens qui ont des brûlés pour ce
mandat non métier pour ouvrir la piste
est bonne on n'est pas une idée qui
était parce que les grecs les romains il
y avait l'idée que la terre était au
centre de l'univers
il y avait une espèce de yas mais ce qui
était beau et il y avait un désir
d'esthétique puis de perfection dans un
sens et et il y avait cinq ans y était
quand tout tu étais genre organisée à
cause de ce désir le ou d'autre que de
cette manière de voir le monde de cette
manière de vouloir voir le mont bleu il
ya eu d'autres il voyait vraiment comme
la terre au centre avec des sphères
autour puis donc il voyait pas du tout
s'appuie cette idée là est resté près
vraiment super longtemps c'est surtout
le moyen âge bon c'était pas la période
où est-ce qu'ils ont le plus d'activités
scientifiques en en occident mais
éventuellement à prêter dans les années
60 70 voire des années 7e sexy en
retient aucun chiffre je finis par en
retenir
quelques-unes mais je suis vraiment
cordonnier mal chaussé là pour une
astrophysicienne sais c'est dur même
l'invention du télescope puis qu'on
était capable de voir par exemple que
jupiter avait quatre choses qui tournait
autour testé comme impossible de
l'ignorer que tu voyais les points se
déplacer d'un jour à l'autre puis
s'était tu pouvais tout expliquer ça
comme ils sont en orbite autour de
jupiter a fait que des cadres à qui bon
qu'il faut revoir notre modèle
puis l'heure en effet en effet que ce
qui l'attend répond au centre de
l'univers
le soleil est au centre du système
solaire pour éventuellement se rendent
compte que cela est en orbite autour de
centre des galaxies piqué ya d'autres
galaxies et que leur séquence
effectivement c'est au tour du sale
c'est ce que je disais tantôt c'est que
fait mais maintenant je le dois rentrer
dans la section est ce que je veux poser
plein de questions puis et coutances
si on a les réponses j'imagine qu'il ya
plein de questions que je me pose qui on
a sûrement même pas de découvrir les
réponses encore effectivement confirme
ans ce que ce que je crois qui est vrai
par rapport au big bang l'univers est
encore en constante expansion je pense
que c'est une réalité
oui pis admettons comprendre l'origine
du big bang et ce qu'on sait il sait
partie de ou donc dans quelle direction
maintenant l'autre une idée de gens
c'est ça ok le carton décède à parler du
big bang c'est là que le cerveau est
mort c'est qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est
si le stock le site est comme partout
c'est par nick et moi non plus je pas
content mais c'est cela répond aux
pauvres et c'est comme partout il ya pas
un endroit où a commencé l'univers on
sait que à l'origine ce qu'on appelle le
big bang c'est que le début le début de
l'univers c'est que toute la matza tout
ce qu'on connaît là étaient concentrés
dans un point infiniment petit mais
c'est quoi ça toutes les galères qu'il
existe tout exister tout ce qui existait
existe encore puyoô pour rien que c'est
créer un nouveau baisse qui atteint peu
tout c'est comme si beau premièrement il
n'y avait rien avant le big bang tu peux
pas dire genre qu'est ce qu'ils avaient
avant le big bang c'est comme demander
qu'est-ce qui honore du bonheur de votre
temps non c'est l'espace temps a été
créé au big bag et puis là quand ça va
compenser l'espace et le temps été créée
puis tranquillement pas vite la matière
s'est complexifié au début c'est comme
trop chaud et puis le juste supposer
combine des grills c'était mal gros
chiffre astronomique mois s'imaginer
plus gros chiffre images c'était très
très chaude antiaériens des plus quelque
chose plus c'est chaud - des choses
compliquées peuvent rester une femme
donc
et comme dans notre vie de tous les
jours mais bon bref et ça s'est refroidi
tranquillement pas vite et ça le prix de
l'expansion à différents rythmes donc
comme toute une histoire le du du début
de l'univers avec une grosse une rapide
et qu'aucune subvention qui après savez
ça c'est comme refroidi les premiers
atomes se sont faire former donc si on
sait que le l'atome d'hydrogène c'est la
tombe le plus simple donc lyon c'est qui
s'est formée pas mal d'hydrogène un
petit peu d'hélium qui comme le 12e à
tombe le plus hype qui après ce bain
tranquillement pas vite tout ça s'est
refroidi ben ça leur fait notre univers
mais non encore aujourd'hui l'on se pose
tellement de questions si c'est vraiment
pas c'est vraiment pas un sujet facile à
à comprendre ni à expliquer je rap mé
ont l'effectif et que ça veut dire que
maintenant l'âge de notre galaxie au
réel techniquement la démarche que de
les droguer réaction ben on sait que
l'univers a à peu près 13,8 milliards
d'années plus il ya plein de façons de
le calculer mais justement en remontant
dans le temps mais je ne saurais pas
expliquer les détails à chaud comme ça
et puis on sait que notre galaxie ben on
est vraiment vieille aussi mais ses yeux
comme une certaine il ya un flou le
selon les méthodes qu'on utilise par
exemple on est capable de mesurer large
de tels objets dans notre galaxie pluie
c'est 12,8 milliards d'années on est
capable de mesurer tel ou tel autre
objet puis lui c'est un peu plus pilotes
sont un peu moins un fait que l'on n'est
pas une grosse ya un gros flou mais mes
ouailles les galaxies se serait formé
bon pas tout en même temps on sait qu'il
y en a qui sont plus vieilles donc quand
tu regardes bon le ceser la fameuse la
vitesse de la lumière est finie donc ça
veut dire que ça va vraiment vite en
lumière tu nous on a l'impression c'est
instantané
sauf que c'est sûr parce que nous comme
humain n'est pas capable de percevoir ce
mais on ne suit souvent lui dit que si
on était capable de détendre le soleil
ça nous prendrait huit minutes avant de
s'en rendre non
parce que ça prend à 8 minutes à la
lumière pour franchir la distance qui
nous sépare pardon une soleil fait
qu'une vue que la lumière un repos à une
vitesse infinie ben quand on regarde
dans l'espace avec nos télescopes
on est capable de voir des choses qui
plus ici un monde unique sera plus sont
loin plus ça fait longtemps qu'ils sont
que ce convoi est vrai plus ça fait
longtemps que leur lumière est
particulier parce que ça le client
certain temps venir qui à un moment
donné mais on est capable de voir des
affaires qui ça fait très très très
longtemps la peau 13,8 me home et il
avait très très très long mais qui en
est capable de voir que les galaxies
dépôt exactement de la même manière
vite et nous autres notre galaxie je
sais pas si tu déjà vu une image le 2
comme on pense que salo l'herne de
galaxies donc la galaxie le sait toutes
les étoiles qui sont autour du soleil et
donc le soleil fait partie de la galaxie
il ya défaut une petite confusion anti
système solaire pigalle aksil le système
solaire c'est le sochaux c'est planète
les planète naine pluton
mais c'est pas le seul système solaire
de la galaxie qui elle comprend quelques
centaines de milliards d'étoilés chaque
chaque étoile et un soleil pour un
système
c'est vraiment un coup j'espère qu'à
voir par là a pris mais tous ceux avec
des observations t on
c'est dur de savoir de quoi la loire
notre galaxie parce que on est dedans
avec les enfants les survols analogique
commandes du frevo savoir de quoi ton
école alors cité dans l'école peut pas
le droit de sortir c'est parce que c'est
vraiment impossible d'envoyer ensemble
pour prendre une photo de notre voie
lactée
mais bon bref on était capable de voir
si on mesure la distance des étoiles on
est capable comme ceux de se faire une
genre de carte puis on sait que ça le
lardin espèce de spirale d'enfants
imagine une assiette ok c'est que c'est
vraiment plus
et puis les étoiles sont organisées sur
des broc qui forment des spirales
c'est vraiment fun qui cumule comme
forme et puis on pense que pour former
des galaxies comme ça ça prend des
collisions entre des galaxies qui serait
plus comme des genres de deux sphères
genre avec lui sous des toiles dans le
centre
c'est grave mais on se rend très loin
c'est comme un siphon centrale il ya des
gens qui font des simulations numériques
de sera donc ils font ils fabriquent des
galaxy dans leurs ordinateurs
veepee puis on est capable de montrer
que tu es en faisant collisionner équipe
en faisant entrer en collisions de
galaxies en cas de former des galaxies
spirales donc ça nous indique que notre
galaxie est peut-être bonne nouvelle
bien mais c'est vieux port et le pi 5 po
et on ne sait pas avec précision mais ça
peut être très long après qu'une vague
se soient créés pour que baisse a pas
été très bons sur les chaînes l'univers
le big bang ça ferait repli 13,8
millions d'années la galaxie un peu
moins inquiet la terre à la cua 4,5
millions d'années avec méthode et
système siv la planète au bout du monde
à terre on sait ce sens et ce pic à
mâcon c'est ce qu'on coupe un arbre
ben on les a mais pas et il ya toutes
sortes de façons se sait plus les
géologistes qui tu dis que tu dis ça
mais avec les roches entre autres qu'on
est capable de dater avec des
radioactivité donc on connaît quand même
assez bien tout est différent at on
botte en touche parler de l'hydrogène de
l'hélium et ça continue la suite le donc
plus de deux protons puis d'électrons ça
c'est des petites particules qu'on est
vraiment pas capable de voir mais qu' on
est capable d'étudier plus ya en europe
à mesure qu on en ajoute ça fait
différents éléments chimiques
donc vous avez déjà entendu les noms
latins oxygène un gone mais il y en a
qui sont radioactifs
ben c'est se mêler la radioactivité ben
c'est ça ça varie dans le temps puis ça
c'est une le juge sans que je tentais
d'expliquer les choses qui pose tout mon
domaine mais j'ai déjà appris ce qu'est
on est capable de mesurer comme ça ça
fait combien de temps dès que ça que là
que la terre des enfants mondial de
mesure et l'âge des roches comme ça au
pire ça mais me semble si je me souviens
bien mon cursus c'est que c'est en
étudiant parce que il expliqué que
toutes les roches de la terre on ont été
refondus dans le magma et fac les roches
de l'origine sur la terre sont pilonnés
qu on est très mal on appris des des
météorites arrêté car est éparpillée à
la création de la terrasse on veut
qu'ils seraient retombés cette roche le
à la mer morte à terme et elles étaient
intacts depuis tous quand le psy elle
conte dessus non non c'est un bon point
c'est vrai parce que c'est vrai que sur
terre il ya beaucoup d'activité
géologique puis les plus vieilles roches
de raisons doivent pas être aussi
vieille que la planète par contre quand
tu regardes et les astéroïdes puis
éventuellement qu'un astéroïde sous une
roche dans le monde
mais quand ça arrive il y en a qui
arrivent sur terre pis si ça tombe par
terre on aperçoit un météorite puis aux
autres c'est vrai que ben c'est rester
no touch et de ministre de l'information
de systèmes sa visite qu'on ne peut dire
aussi c'est que mais le soleil s'est
formé puis autour du soleil il y avait
en ce qu'on appelle un disque
protoplanétaire dans ce sens que c'est
là que les planètes se forment
puis c'est là que les planètes se sont
formées pitt est bon ça prend un certain
temps pour former des planètes mais
c'est pas si long que ceux non plus fait
que c'est le soleil est un peu plus
vieux mais tout ça pourrait nous mener
justement à notre sujet de prédilection
deux journées qui la vie mais ton qu'ils
ont c'est justement la planète à peu
près stable à 4,5 milliards piqué la vie
tu arrivais pas tellement longtemps
après non c'est ce pays témoin les
chiffrent en milliards ça me dit rien
pantoute
mais dans cosmos il utilise une analogie
le calendrier cosmique genre j'en
utilise un autre occupe certes il y met
toute la durée de tout l'univers sur une
année de calendrier
big bang 1er janvier aujourd'hui c'est
on est le 31 décembre presque minuit
mais moi j'aime ça le faire pour
l'histoire de la terre parce que ça nous
donne une super bonne idée
en tout cas ça nous donne une bonne idée
de l'histoire d'avis sur terre c'est que
faisons-le ans baby fait qu' il ya 4,56
je crois milliards d'années la terre
s'est formé on va dire que ça c'est le
1er janvier et qui aujourd'hui mais on
est le 31 décembre presque arrivé à me
la halle de conclure non mais comme ces
cellules et puis j'aime ce me poser la
question le têtu je pense qu'hélas la
vie est arrivé quand là dedans parce que
c'est ça qui nous aide à comprendre à
quel point ce que toute l'histoire et
qui est d'après vous mettons qui mettons
le 1er janvier fait de la création de la
terre moi ça représente quoi comment
est-ce qu'une planète apparaît c'est
quand est ce qu'on dit parce que
maintenant pour pour être capable de
répondre à sous-estimer une réponse
vraiment qui va être loin de la réalité
sous main la tentation faut cacher tes
c'est quoi le 1er janvier à minuit à 00
il est avait comme une boule de lave ou
dans au québec c'est le disque
protoplanétaire fait pour former je
pense qu'on va revenir à former une
étoile
huawei bac 2 en fait j'ai fait quelque
chose qui s'appelle la danse des moines
et je la fais lui larmes mais comme il
ya une ya des trucs dans l'espace qui
s'appelle des nébuleuses
c'est plein de poussière c'est plein de
gaz s'est récrié diffultés promènerez
l'autre je serais probablement pauvre
nul c nul ils peur de ça intéressant
donc une raison par exemple je sais pas
une étoile qui explose à proximité il
faut juste en se déplaçant le autour de
la galaxie
parce que ces nuages là aussi se
promènent autour de la galaxie mais il
va il va y avoir un espèce de mouvement
de compression qui va faire que les
petites particules vont commencer à se
rapprocher
puis on sait comment que la gravité
fonctionne plus tôt
proche plus de goût de rapprocher donc
la gravité fait que donc plus d'épreuves
de goûter le projet puis abandonné ben
ça va faire que dans le centre il va
s'allumer une étoile donc il va y avoir
tellement de matière à la même place qui
va pouvoir y avoir de fusion nucléaire
c'est ce qui définit une étoile quelque
chose qui est capable de briller par
elle-même
grâce à la fusion nucléaire dans son
coeur c'est que y'a de l'hydrogène qui
tend à transformer en hélium puisque ça
dégage beaucoup d'énergie
on aimerait bien se reproduire ça sur
terre d'ailleurs j'ai vu que ça il ya
des gens qui travaillent la turquie et
des sceaux les bains faire de l'énergie
grâce au même processus que ça ça donne
de l'énergie infinie ouais c'est pas si
simple que ça par exemple une centrale
nucléaire c'est pas son nom et sa reine
vierge c'est le contraire tu prends des
grosses des gros a tant pis tu laissais
pas la fission fait qu'on est en train
d'essayer le sait on jamais pression
cette conversation là va être une série
de parenthèse on est en train d'essayer
de retirer des étoiles en reproduisant
le phénomène que tu nous expliquer
autrement on veut pas récréer des
étoiles on veut faire l'énergie
d'énergie avec moi-même procession
exactement exactement c'est pas du tout
on n'est pas proche le quai mais il ya
des gens qui trichent pas s'il ya des
des gros parce qu'ils construisent des
grosses affaires c'est u 10 et u les
atomes qui tourne vraiment vite parce
qu'ils veulent les phares se percutent
ceux ci montrent à faire les
accélérateurs de particules ça permet de
mieux comprendre la matière entre autres
utilisent des prix similaires mais plus
je sais que je vais vraiment pour les
autres voudraient créer des trous noirs
maîtresse et ça c'est dans une matière
qui parlait mais c'est fascinant en
clair vous en parler à mon tour était
déjà qui travaillait au cern depuis tout
lasse et c'est vraiment un sujet très
fin mais bryant ton étoile est allumée
ou dans l'écrit mais il reste un paquet
de cochonneries auto écrire c'est parce
qu'à terme le fait qu'une excellent père
ni la poussière autour qui ont pas
toutes la même température
parce qu'évidemment ceux qui sont plus
proches sans abeilles sont plus choqués
et puis dans ses disques
protoplanétaires le bas il ya des
collisions puis en fait les collisions
ce comme un peu de stress mouthe
c'est souvent ce qui va arriver c'est
que il va redoutent particules qui vont
se croiser ils vont rester collés
ensemble
donc ils s'agglutinent puis c'est comme
ça à force de collisions qu'on va
réussir à créer des petits astéroïdes
dépit des choses de plus en plus gros
jusqu'à temps que sa forme d
protoplanète puis éventuellement que sa
forme des planètes
si sur une idée du temps que ça prend ah
oui mais j'avoue que je sais pas que le
chiffre la bâtisse et genre de l'heure
de jeu désiré c'est des millions
d'années dans la main mais je me suis
pris au jeu palois a très bien fait que
une fois te ramasser ton espèce de coeur
de roche si c'est assez massif l'on
pense qu'il s'est enclenché un processus
pour accumuler des gosses étaient dans
notre système solaire il ya des planètes
rocheuses puis à des planètes gazeuses
lee planète rocheuse dans notre système
solaire mercure vénus tu appris quelque
chose
mongai certaines chansons lemay pour
savoir les planètes rocheuses sur sa
volée planète quoi l'élève c'est mon ami
mon vieux mon salut mon vieux tu m'a
jeté sur une nouvelle moi je t'ai que la
planète ait pu le point positif c'est
salut mon vieux tu m'a jeté ce sommet
ouvert en net
ouais mais je pense qu'à s'arrêter sur
un nuage parce que le plus temps entre
reparlé depuis ton petit une histoire de
temps mais bref fois il est donc mercure
vénus terre et mars c'est les petites
planètes rocheuses de notre système
solaire
mais il ya aussi des plus grosses
planètes jupiter saturne uranus et
neptune et aux autres on pense que c'est
parce qu'il y avait accumulé tellement
grosses qu'on fait un cas assez gros et
qui ont pu commencer à accumuler aussi
des gaz puis abandonnée
il ya un processus c'est l'équivalent
d'une boule de neige qui descendent
côtes notamment donné ça ça s'accumule
très vite donc ce processus qui permet
de construire des géantes gazeuses
ça c'est ce qu'on c'est toute l'histoire
compenser dans notre système solaire
avant maintenant on connaît tellement
d'autres sortes de planètes que entre
qu'il ya plein de nuances mais ça c'est
l'histoire qu'on avait avant donc c'est
comme ça qu'on forme une planète qui
veut que ça se forme justement par un
bagde donc c'est chaud c'est super chaud
début et puis ça c'est comme si tout est
fondu dans un sens puis les choses les
plus lourdes vont comme coulée dans le
centre donc les méthodes et nous autres
notre planète et un choeur qui plus est
ce qui est plus avec des matériaux plus
lourds
puis jusqu'à la croûte qui est bondé des
matériaux plus légers mais ça reste à
roche qui éventuellement c'était comme
notre notre terre au début donc le jeu
sait pas où est ce qu'on partie chrono
mais moi aussi aisément là mais disons
qu'on a une belle boule de roche qui est
pas mal en lave puis leur faut que tu
poses la question dans le fond est ce
que la vie est apparue vite puis à quel
point vite mipo vite c'est à quel point
possible pour répondre à la fameuse
question avez vous quand vous pensez que
la vie est apparue si on ramène toute
l'histoire la planète terre sur une
année calendrier c'est tellement j'étais
n'ont aucune référence mais tandis que
m'a faite et le 15 janvier je veux dire
aux alentours du 15 janvier
ben moi je crois le savoir parce qu'il
me semble que tu veux tu entendu de
quelques pas puis même somme qui
essayait dans le mode mars écoutes
effectuées
oui c'est vrai et effectivement c'est ça
aurait pu être comme quasiment
instantané d'un processus plus long
parce qu'au début tout qu'un séjour de
la lâcheté programmant le goût de vivre
dans le coin du mois de mars et là que
la vie serait la première de l'histoire
de la planète
ce qu'au début avaient pas d'ogm tout
donné mais pas d'où il a pas d'argent
n'a pas rien non c'est cela la planète
des gaz et un peu donc les palets lille
est il ce qui constitue notre atmosphère
s'est construite plein de façons mais
entre autres par le dégazage on sait les
gosses qui étaient contenues dans cette
boule de roche le pays
ils sont sortis d'écoles de la planète
qui effectivement le l'atmosphère s'est
construit puis je pense que tu es au
début il pleuvait sans arrêt le triste
et comme en tout cas c'est toute une
histoire le sait pas c'est pas une place
où tu avais le goût d'être au début dit
et fait évidemment c'était pas des
humains qui est des leurs mais même si
les formes de vie les plus simples qui
sont apparues et s'apprend comme on a
dit tout à l'heure c'est caen qui fait
trop chaud où il n'y a pas grand chose
de complexe qui peut survivre vite et
l'histoire de la vie dans l'univers puis
de nouveau dans dans un final c'est une
histoire de choses qui se sont
complexifiées cd fois entre quand
j'étais au bac en physique j'étais avec
une gamme de gaulle qui a fait pour
congo des boîtes que s'il y avait une
certaine des voix arrogance et que les
goys trouvé que la physique c'est
vraiment comme une science que vraiment
science j'ai beaucoup pensé mais comme
noble ouais c'est ça petit que les
autres sciences rester comme un peu
moins parce que c'est rops et réputé
difficile
ces vêtements sales et séverine of may
mais entre coiffure et le fait qu'il y
avait comme une espèce d'échelle
justement pas d'accord parce qu'en fait
en physique on étudie les choses les
plus simples
c'est en réalité une étoile c'est
tellement plus simple que toi puis moi
tu sais moi que des fois quand quand je
regarde le ton ce qui étudie la vie
microscopique lé c'est compliqué plus
quand tu arrives avec des histoires si
on parle beaucoup de santé mentale ces
temps-ci bits et essaye de comprendre
ces bons titres sur des pressions en
burn-out si vous avez des zus sonia
lupien récemment ainsi entre autres
toute cette science le moi quand je lis
l'atuge comme oh my god que c'est
compliqué genre le cerveau humain ici
c'est un unis
soit c'est ça exactement exactement puis
moi je me sens comme si je me sens que
j'ai lu à isaac asimov cas chez les plus
jeunes
peut-être que certains de vos auditeurs
et auditrices dont l'on dit je lui aussi
pu y avait toute une série qui déconne
imaginez que on était capable de comme
prédire ce que les sociétés allaient
refaire la série fondation
vieillissement ça m'avait fait
réellement compliqué mais bref
l'astrophysique c'est quand même
relativement sensible et puis mais la
vie non qui en fait quand on essaye de
refaire de la vie en laboratoire on
n'est pas capable
on n'a jamais été capable c'est à partir
des choses qu'on sait qu'ils forment
lavit et des molécules super compliqué
avec plein de carbone d'oxygène qui
d'hydrogène des molécules organiques
on n'est pas capable on est bon on ne
sait pas qu est ce qui a permis que ça
ça arrive on pensait pas qu'il pourrait
seror non plus en phase avec le on est
homo en mars sur le calendrier de la
planète terre il ya de l'eau il ya de la
roche toutes sortes d'éléments pige au
lendemain il ya des trucs qui se mettent
ensemble de couilles il ya de la vie et
des choses qui bougent par elle-même qui
versera produits ouais bon c'est pas
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on est passé de
2,9 roche à la ville
ben maintenant quel mystère y est un peu
plus pointu succès dont le centre est et
on a des bonnes idées comme un lit malik
et l'organique se sont formés molécules
organiques
parce que c'est la vie où c'est mon
petit encore non c'est comme les briques
inquiet pour faire la main en montée
pour faire la vie ça prend des molécules
organiques jeter des molécules
organiques on m'en trouve genre sur les
astéroïdes ce qui se fait pas on est
capable d'en faire de pleins de façon
différente c'est pas si rare que ce
puits ça c'est peut-être un bon signe
quand on cherche la vie ailleurs dans
l'univers
mais pour faire raison la petite dans
une cellule au plus simple indice est
comme une petite membrane qui protège un
petit bagage génétique
le petit bagage génétique qui est encore
dit avec gilad l'adn
l'adn c'est une molécule ultra complexes
avec plein plein de deux molécules
organes avec moins de d'acides aminés
fake bref ça on le sait pas comment ça
s'est formé au début mais il ya plein
d'hypothèses le fait que tu sais pas on
ne sait pas qu'on sait pas comment ken
roche est devenu un sens oui je le serai
c'est plus pointu que ça mais le petit
sparkle un moment donné dans le
processus
ça reste sympa c'est fou ces mots c'est
une des choses qui me qui me fait plus
capoter comment connais pas assez
justement kaman et il ya des organismes
unicellulaires at-il quelque chose qui
va avec les gauches par lui même s'il
n'y avait rien qui bougeait pas par soi
même
celui là il veut bouger ils vont se
reproduire mais il veut transmettre son
illustre et ses répliques et 6 mai
peut-être même un point quand même qui
est intéressant parce que dans la
recherche en astrobiologie qui est comme
une espèce de sciences qui chapeaute
août la recherche de vie ailleurs dans
l'univers
puis dans la recherche sur la vie en
général dont la vie sur terre aussi
s'est il ya déjà pu en biologie déjà il
ya une difficulté à définir c'est quoi
qui vivent leur présentement sujet du
jour c'est le fameux virus
on est un virus selon la définition
france largement acceptée c'est pas
vivant mais ça veut se reproduire fait
qu t il y a des gens qui y proposent que
ça serait pas nécessairement comme un
déclic mais que ce serait plutôt comme
une espèce de dévolution évolution moins
de choses qui seraient de plus en plus
complexes vite et peut-être d'un côté on
est capable d ottawa ça c'est clair que
c'est vivant puis l'autre côté homme
comme moi c'est clair que c'est pas
vivant mais qui a quelque part entre les
deux il y aurait quand même une zone
qu'en suivant si on le sait pas les
virus d'ailleurs je peux au courant de
tous les détails mais je sais que c'est
un des sujets débattus le testu vivant
c'est pas vivant pitt et je pense que là
où le bât blesse pour les virus et qui
ont besoin d'un autre dont pays
non nous
mais mais bref c'est ça c'est pas si sa
une que seuls de définir la vie mais un
moment donné il ya eu la vie que s'est
créée à peu près au mois de mars de
notre calendrier cosmique puis ça
c'était les ddd bactéries super simple
etd des bactéries avec juste une cellule
puis éventuellement assez rapidement te
dis mon année on parlait beaucoup le
design bleues vertes dans la clarté qui
se reproduisait puis ça rendait avec
saint germain coincé ça c'était vraiment
poche pour tout les gens que je pense
que c'est encore un très gros problème
mais ça ces bactéries la lacune cause
des problèmes dans nos lacs
c'est pas mal dans les espèces de vie
les plus vieilles qu'on connaît en
chance pour trois infractions ne sont
pas payés résilient avec bref ça c'est
arrivé très vite
mais après le l'autre question que
j'aime poser c'est est-ce que tu as une
idée ou est ce qui arrive les dinosaures
dans cette histoire prestige et oublier
les détails des autres le west qui
arrive précisément mais non les
dinosaures mais je le suis je seek mg et
on la vit vraiment simple mettons unis
celle là ça dure est vraiment le sien
durant sa durée vraiment vraiment
longtemps mais qui choisir choisir modo
à l'automne bourgeoisie mois de novembre
ouais voilà où j'irai à l'automne aussi
là mais c'est pire que ça s'est mis des
as à me moquer ses sofitel et 19 ans
entendu que ça fait quand même un
méchant bout tu fais tu le sais ça fait
que ça nous donne une bonne idée de
l'histoire de la vie sur la terre c'est
vraiment juste une histoire de micros se
sont dits de vie très simple qui a mené
c'est sûr ça s'est complexifiée des
organismes multicellulaires je me suis
peut-être septembre les organismes et
leurs maîtres qui étaient quant à eux tu
parlais des arbres les arbres s comme
une merveille qui a pris beaucoup de
temps avant d'être de gruda être créée
ou a été dévalué était donc donc c'est
ça moi ça me frappe toujours viser ce
sam
c'est une des choses qui me dit acquis
de la vie extraterrestre
probablement mais des civilisations les
chansons sont plus faibles et là l
association galactiques avec plein
d'idées de tes propres qui ont tout
l'air d'être des jumeaux mais maison
c'est bien ce que sur ce calendrier le
15 ce qu'est la vie qui était observe
observable à l'oeil est apparue t cm
tous les dinosaures sont arrivés sauf
qu'ils ne sont pas arrivés
non non c'est inutile mais il ya eu des
organismes sont devenus d'organismes
multicellulaires train qui l'avaient
amené sont devenus assez gros pour qu'on
puisse les lire marc n est pas un
poisson corse et ça fait maintenant
mettant un petit poisson était justement
un petit poisson des chenaux
c'est vraiment plus tard c'est et je ne
saurais pas dire exactement les lits
date métissé ça doit être dans l'été au
plus tôt fait que s'il y avait des
utilisations qui s'était posé il ya eu
plus de chances qu'on arrive qu'on
trouve mettons éventuellement une
planète avec un petit poisson des
chenaux qu'avec un espèce
deux sociétés de reptiles mais ce qui
s'offre un homme fascinant c'est que
justement qu'est la vie du moins une
hissé leur drapeau ni vraiment
rapidement décliné qu'il ya eu les
conditions propices à ce qu'on nous
autres qu'on connaît de la vie nous dans
une température au pire de l'eau
maintenant il ya de la vie
fac des planètes où est-ce qu'on puisse
imaginer qu'il y aurait une température
pas pire pitteloud opus imaginez quand
nous ce qu'on ne trouvait des claires et
précises mais ton qui aurait des
conditions qui selon ce qu'on sait
qu'ils seraient propices à la vie comme
on la connaît ici question qui pourrait
prendre beaucoup de temps
ça dépend mais on peut on peut se lancer
là dedans oui et non le thé dansant ce
qu'on a dit de ce conseil on a des bons
prospects l'espèce de l'isl dans une
galaxie près de chez vous qui reçoivent
leurs mais le crédit visite aura un
autre peut-être mais peut-être que mons
on est vraiment triste parce qu'elle nie
on est quand même limité et et moi ça
fait pas mal longtemps le kg tizié les
exoplanètes j'ai commencé mes études
l'adage c'est en 2010 c'est que ça fait
assez longtemps que je baigne là-dedans
avoir l'impression maintenant presque
que c'est comme c'est comme normal mais
des fois on oublie à quel point détecter
des planètes dans d'autres systèmes
solaires c'est offre était encore dans
notre système solaire le genre plutôt
ont été détectés dans les années 50
ces notices de réseaux leur képi après
quand tu penses à l'immensité de
l'espace des genres ce sujet monsieur
pour donner des idées de grandeur
je retiens des chiffres des fous
amoureux aider à avoir des idées de
grandeur
on a envoyé une sonde récemment
pour explorer plus temps c'est lassant
your eyes a pris des photos dont le puy
on voit comme un coeur genre lorsque
vous irez voir des images de plus tant
on a vu plus tôt c'est vraiment encore
plus compliquée qu'on pense et puis plus
facilement compenser ça c'était vraiment
comme une belle déconvenue en même temps
ça a pris ensemble de soins ça a été
vraiment long parce que quand qui l'ont
envoyé pluton était encore une planète
fixé avant 2006 ce qui est arrivé il ya
pas si longtemps que cela fait que ça a
pris vraiment longtemps le genre 1°
offre complètement luis et s'il faut que
la trajectoire soit parfaite mais fait
qu'on connaisse une des choses aussi qui
est qu'il plus fascinant c'est à quel
point
si on a découvert mettons les lois de
l'univers de la gravité compagnie n'a
plein d'autres clones est capable de
prédire traité nostradamus le qui
prédisaient des affaires le typique et
c'est comme si l'on on est une estrade
amusé next level de non sens qu'on est
capable de dire d'un genre les 10
milliards de nos petits milliards mais
tu y mets ton 10000 à quelques mètres va
passer ici si j'envoie ce à telle force
at-elle vitesse ils valent exactement
fou quelle silhouette à bouche pendant
ce temps là en tout le jeu suit ça c'est
cool la mécanique céleste s'est rendu ça
prouve à quel point les formules qu'on
ne trouvait pour décrire l'univers
fonctionne parce que mika va de plus pas
vraiment de façon très précise des
événements qui vont se passer dans le
futur
ouais qui
c'est fou c'est le fun de penser à ce
que je sais pas mon temps avant il y
avait maintenant une éclipse de soleil
le nom aussi la place entre nous qui
célèbre sa cache le soleil
maintenant on est capable de calculer
avec précision c'est que ça va se passer
pitt août le tintin de cbd
mais on met avant quand on voyait se
tait les différentes civilisations qui
observaient ça a été comme il y en a
plein qui attribue sa de la magie c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui était encore il ya
beaucoup de monde qui font ça et on
observe des phénomènes inexpliqués puis
il y en a qui ont tendance à faire comme
encaissés comme une preuve de thé d'une
force surnaturelle ou de chez pas des
extraterrestres est déjà ici l'été des
civilisations super avancées qui sont
ici mais on les voit pas si je veux dire
moi je veux vraiment pas comme rabais
sur youtube comme juge et les croyances
déjà mais comme il n'y a vraiment pas
beaucoup de chance
pis c'est comme cela dans l'histoire
qu'il ya des mystères on travaille là
dessus qu'ils ont les résout pis on a
une espèce de prêt ainsi penser en ce
label le rasoir d'occam qui est que s'il
ya quelque chose qui peut être expliqué
de manière vraiment enceinte ou vraiment
compliqué la façon vraiment simple c'est
probablement la bonne réponse
on a beaucoup tendance en sciences à huy
des choses mystérieuses et fois qui
arrivent mais on va essayer de trouver
une explication qui n'implique pas qu'il
ya une civilisation extraterrestre
parce que le plus de chance exactement
c'est mais à chaque fois aussi con qu'on
savait pas on ne sut quand le fil par le
savent on s'est rendu compte que c'était
beau succès historique maha date 100 %
des choses inexplicables qu'on a réussi
à expliquer évidemment c'était pas des
irlandais
mais ça veut pas dire qu'un jour ça se
passe mais ça va prendre des pics rose
preuve six sa séquence egan qui disait
le x-mini cniid
oui ça prend des preuves qui sont
extraordinaires pour faire des annonces
qui sont extraordinaires on s'en
souvient régulièrement les autres mais
si on revient à noter système solaire et
donner une idée grande a demandé combien
de temps dans l'appli pour seront
mémorisées
en astronomie on utilise beaucoup une
petite grandeur s'appelle l' unité
astronomique
c'est tout simplement la distance
moyenne entre à terre puis le soleil
et puis on pense pas à quel point notre
système solaire est vaste donc entre à
tapis soleil aux unités astronomiques
mais plutôt en est à peu près 40 unités
astronomiques du soleil exactement du
soleil ouais donc fixé c'est ça c'est
super vaste qu'il haute idée de grandeur
que j'allais devenir selon g au soleil
dans le fond de plus tard d'ici un nom
bien que souvent ça dépanne on met un
pied à elle veut très proche le temps
juste juste maintenant que je fabule de
corps ouais exercices de passes et non
ça depuis je pense d'ailleurs lyon je
pense pas mes yeux il ya 10 des
observatoires du soleil le qu'existe ce
qui se rapproche le thé pour aller mieux
observer les parce que tu es le soleil
c'est comme l'étoile la plus proche de
nous c'est on peut l'étudier vraiment en
grands détails donc beaucoup beaucoup à
apprendre du soleil puis il y en a eu
des chercheurs ici à montréal qui se
spécialise là dans le lit du soleil fait
qu'entre c'est super mais pour pour se
donner une idée parce que le système
solaire est grand il ya foule de vivre
dans le système solaire c'est envoyer
une fusée ou une sonde ne doit pas
frapper des astéroïdes lettre c c'est
super vaste mais même quand tu passes à
travers la ceinture d'astéroïdes
des fois on imagine que tu as super
dense ne salit pas et puis
mais en dehors de notre système solaire
est encore plus de vide donc new rising
qui la chose la plus rapide qu'on n'a
jamais construite en tant qu'humanité si
on voulait l'envoyer vers proxima du
centaure qui l'étoile la plus proche
le on
quand c est ce qu on sait juste courte
parenthèse sur proxima du centaure est
ce qu on sait qui est ce qu'il ya un
système solaire autour de ce soleil ce
qui est des planètes 6 campion les cons
les a retrouvés on les a vus si mme
aubry était fermé la parenthèse en
retournant après tu fais que sim et on
va envoyer une sonde à site vers ce
système solaire le ça prendrait genre
des dizaines de milliers d'années
des dizaines de milliers d'effets extra
plat qu'on ai baisé à pouvoir dire on
est capable d'aller voir plus ton
salaire de quoi c'est déjà très longue
mais on peut pas vraiment les prendre
les aspects des planètes à - est à 4,4
chose années lumière sera rendu le on
n'utilise plus l'unité astronomique
parce que ça serait un grave un chiffre
trop grande utilisent les années lumière
ce cette unité lui est un mélange entre
parce que yoann est dedans fait que ça
laisserait croire qu est-ce que c'est
une unité de temps mais non sunnites et
de distance parce que c'est la distance
que la lumière parcours en un an
puis on est 18 heures la lumière ça
voyage très vite mais ça voyage à une
vitesse finit toujours la même dans le
vide fait qu'on est capable comme ceux
de désir d'enfant si ça c'est que si
c'est la même chose que les plus tard
jeudi avec le soleil si proxima du
centaure je peux y arriver quelque chose
avec elle je sais pas qu'est ce qui
pourrait arriver mais c'est sa lumière
s'éteint je suis pas quelqu'un même un
gros truc devant ça prendrait quatre 4
ans et quelques avant qu'on le sache pas
ce que la lumière qu'on 80 quelle
piscine était capable de voyager 2 et
lumières pendant 1 4% catalan
mais on est loin pour voyager avec des
aliments afssa prendrait d'édition des
milliers d'années exactement pitt est ce
ça amène aussi l'idée de la
communication avec des extraterrestres
potentiels ces gens même si on avait la
chance le cas d'une civilisation après
que siemens entend ce qui est vraiment
vraiment pas du tout prouvé ou autre
mais le tête envoie un petit message le
salut comment ça va ouais ça prend 4,1
dépenses la rétrogradation fort qu'il
suit texto sa droite répondent leçons du
bon goût c'est facile et c'est cette
génération construit miss après des
incidents d'accès qui en fait il était
seulement un problème à beaucoup plus
petite échelle c'est pour tout ce qu on
quand on imagine les divers jeux mais
quand on pense à envoyer une colonie sur
mars
la communication sera pas instantanée
non plus et ça peut être genre 20
minutes le décalage côté georges à ta
famille spots sommes totons fils né
ménage sur mac j'espère faire des zooms
je pense et ce que j'espère que mon fils
repos comme un des promis genre
colonisateur de mars est pas ce que je
pourrais lui parler comme un deal est
bon c'est ça prend le temps pour pour
parce que dans le fond l'information
quand on se parle avec des ondes radio
ça se déplace à la vitesse de la lumière
est importante donc voilà puis le lac
est ce que je retiens c'est un peu là
mais est ce que on est ce qu'on est ce
qu'il ya des recherches qui se fond pour
essayer de trouver une façon d'accélérer
nos déplacements ou nos communications
ou tout seul oui c'est un peu la lumière
j'imagine c'est city state unité qui
existent mais apprécié ces camions ne
sait maintenant il ya dessus tu manques
notamment de rechercher ces quads dans
star wars de la cuy mais oui oui c'est
clair la pi pi ca va du plus long du
plus concret et réaliste et ça se passe
présentement au plus comme hypothétique
et c'est plutôt comme les auteurs de
science-fiction et 10 amusé à imaginer
des choses mais oui c'est clair loti je
pense que je ne sais pas à quel point
c'est c'est
par défaut on aidé des explorateurs des
fois des fois il y en a qui disent que
l'humanité s'est on est comme
colonisateurs dans l'armée on veut comme
conquérir ce match peuvent foule à
l'aise avec ça par exemple quand on
parle de la conquête de l'espace
j'ai une petite gêne dans ma tête on
dirait que ça devrait plus s'appeler
l'exploration de l'espace je suis
vraiment plus à l'aise avec l'idée de
l'exploration que l'idée de conques être
quelque chose d'autre pour moi ça les
notions tellement quand même tout en
nous une oie oui c'est ce dont 6 ou une
femme spawn super attitude bien ça nous
on peut sa peau était super positif
d'avoir cette attitude lui je sais que
vous avez reçus
natasha khan a plus forte avec j'avais
eu le bonheur de partager entre on avait
été invité en même temps tout le monde
en parle qui donc ce titre la
colonisation de l'amérique sept ans
tombe trop doux avec moi je peu folle à
l'aise avec l'idée de conquérir l'espace
mais l'exploration je pense assez à
l'aise avec l'idée passé on veut on veut
apprendre on veut comprendre on le dit
au début tu es les enfants se pose des
questions on veut apprendre on veut
savoir c'est que j'imagine que j'imagine
que c'est par défaut on va vouloir
toujours explorer plus loin et et puis
il ya ça peut nous amener un autre
élément qui comme un peu qui est super
intéressant science fiction c'est le
paradoxe de fermi
le paradoxe de fermi ça a été ça va être
compliqué mais c'est vraiment potes
parce que connaissant plus ferme
legault s'appelait fermi est un
physicien est vraiment brillant le des
années 50 qui s'est posé la question en
fait j'étais assis ils l'ont fait avec
ces jobs à los alamos et puis il est en
train de
et en fait out of the blue il ya dix où
ils sont en parlant des civilisations
extraterrestres puis si on explique un
peu le paradoxe de fermi c'est était là
on a parlé d ordre de grandeur
ça fait 13 8 millions d'années que
l'univers existe deux autres ça fait 4,6
millions d'années qatar existe mais il
ya eu des planètes qui se sont formées
avant cela on sait qu'il ya des étoiles
qui sont plus vieilles
puis ça a été ça a été long mais ça
petit sus ils ont peur parce qu'on ne
peut finir notre calendrier cosmique
mais les dinosaures apparaissent le 15
ils disparaissent au boxing day
disparaissent au putting défi l'humanité
sur le si longtemps quand l'humanité
apparel 31 décembre
mais bref tu es tout seul notre
progression comme une communauté assez
fait super rapide menti quand il regarde
comment ont évolué entre envoyer des
premiers humains sur la lune qui envoyer
une sonde aux confins de notre système
solaire pour explorer plus dont tu as
assez battu par critique si on extrapole
estimait donc mettons qu'il y avait une
civilisation qui serait route et mettons
qu'on comprend là le mot erectus lethu
l'arrivée des hommes préhistoriques
mettons qu'on met sur le 15 décembre ma
place du 31 et métiers s'expliquant même
vitesse de progression de 10,6 d'autres
utilisations qui ont eu quinze jours de
plus que nous aurons moins il serait
sûrement déjà rendu licite à éviter soit
tant que nouveau point les fait vraiment
bien le raisonnement c'est exactement ce
type ça a même pas besoin d'être quinze
jours avant sa droite comme toujours
justes maginez mettons une utilisation
qui traduit mettons un million d'années
plus tôt ou sépia millions sur les
calendriers cosmique syrien l'évolution
d'une solution selon m
si nous ôtons tchad mettons qu'on existe
encore dans un million d'années
on peut même si on n'aime pas produit
pour imaginer technologiquement ou
est-ce qu'on est rendu puis qu'est ce
qu'on fait on pourrait s'imaginer qu'on
sera
justement d'explorer la galaxie contre
était vraiment rendu loin fac pourquoi
qu' aucune civilisation qui aurait un
million d'années d'avancé que son pays
si pékin dit bonjour
exactement mappy le sais ça fait là on
se demande mais pourquoi
puis j'ai l'a amené mon lit aujourd'hui
les ja g-star livre qui a été écrit qui
donne 50 solutions au paradoxe de fermi
je pense qu'une nouvelle édition avec 75
solution qui c'est fascinant de penser à
celle les solutions c'est des
explications pourquoi est ce que je
serai policiers exactement mais vous
vous en avez peut-être une ou deux si
j'ose dire il y en a pas qui n'est pas
une bonne c'est tout le monde peut avoir
sa propre idée de pourquoi qu'ils sont
pourquoi ils sont pas là mais moi une de
mes préférées c'est c'est grand c'est
gris comme un grand puis ai beaucoup de
vide
c'est donc si ça prend le thé on
s'imagine qui en a qui sont capables
d'aller plus vite que notre sont ignorés
zone mais quand même mitigé dire la
vitesse de la lumière est finie donc est
allé plus vite que sur la peine de
visiter ces moments c'est ça mais c'est
une délibération il ya des gens qui
s'intéressent à à nous accéléré oui mais
est-ce qu'il y en ait qui s'intéressent
à nous accélérer plus vite la lumière
comme dans un film de science fiction
pour l'instant le nom lois de la
physique nous disent que s'écrit amont
possible de la lumière ça serait la
vitesse maximum ce serait impossible
d'aller plus vite que son ombre est oui
pour des raisons que je prévois
expliquez moi est ce que tu sais
probablement bien moins que seul pour
garder les laits l'intégrité du corps
humain imagine j'ai pas fait de grosse
que celle ci récemment que et émettant
des fois on image ati réaux car la
vitesse de la lumière loti avec une
technologie maîtrise sans que ça soit un
verseau team et ont dit à tout parler
des ondes radio thé cancon et mais qui
vont en vitesse de la lumière des ondes
radio ça fait quoi une centaine d'années
qu'on hamon ou autre - met en scène
quinze ans qu'on a aimé we fuck
utilisation dans un rayon de 50 ans ni
lumière pourrait potentiellement capable
dans détective se serait rendue jusque
là exactement mais joe ton sec partout
pour des ondes radio puis on n'entend
pas de porte
non sauf qu'il ya beaucoup de docteurs a
appelé ses 7 6 ce programme qui sérieux
qui a été entrepris dans les années 60
pour essayer de d'entendre veut pas
entendre mais en fait de détecter ce
genre des signaux radio le con que nous
on émet depuis une centaine d'années
1 parce que tu es justement à l'époque
de la jupe au monde et du moyen âge là
il n'y avait pas des changes texto le
fait qu'on n'ait m'étais pas autant dans
l'univers donc toutes les civilisations
potentiel qui serait à plus que 110 ch
annie lumière aux autres ils peuvent pas
détecter notre notre rayonnement
l'autre affaire c'est qu'on ne peut
émissaire pour être détectées le fait
que le signal n'est pas fort mais bon
mais nous on essaie de de devoir puis
d'ailleurs on connaît maintenant
beaucoup d'exoplanètes fait qu'est une
façon intelligente de chercher c'est pas
de chercher n'importe où dans le ciel
mais d'aller voir les plats les lits les
étoiles qui ont dit planète évidemment
des planètes qui pour plein de raisons
ressemble un peu à la terre
mais pour l'instant il c'est vrai qu'on
ne peut rien on n'a pas eu de signal qui
avait l'air comme qui ressemblait un
signal qui modulent et enzo transmettre
toutes nos informations avec un signal
c'est qu'il omet 0 1
on ne peut vu ce qu'ils on y est
tellement il ya une femme que j'aimais
beaucoup s'appelle jim barker qui je
pense présentement comme à la tête de
ses tubes je peux certainement été à la
fête toute sa carrière de danse et ipl
utilise toute analogie
si tu prends toutes les zones possibles
dans le fond tout lire
parce qu'on aimait à différentes
fréquences loterie comme le pied à la
radio on peut changer la fréquence mais
il y en a des tonnes de fréquences ou
est-ce qu'on pourrait écouter guillot
détonne d'endroits où on pourrait
écouter fait qu situe combine ces deux
affaires le avec la quantité de découpe
qu'on a fait ou de recherche des signes
on a dit que c'est à peu près pareil
comme avoir cherché l'équivalent d'un
gros verre d'eau dans tout l'océan
infectés ok si tu cherches des poissons
dans l'océan suffit d'un gros effort là
pendant x années 50 ans 60 ans et tu
réussis à regarder dans un verre d'eau
parce qu'elles étaient limitées des
présomptions des seuls poissons dans
mais c'est sa théière personnes qui
résident michael n'y a pas de poisson
dans l'eau c'est en effet ce site une
bonne analogie pour pour dire comme nom
pour l'instant ne rien trouvé mais on
est loin et d'écouté à toutes les
fréquences en permanence par tous moi
j'aime à manger j'ai ma théorie c'est
pourquoi ton n'en veulent pas parce que
l'évolution
c'est tellement une infinité de azor
pinet ville l'infiniti de variables qui
fait que justement à manier de des
organismes unicellulaires je pense pas
que serra
ouais mais je pense que ça évolue à un
poisson qui évolue un autre chose en
autre chose en faisant autre chose puis
l'espace des infiniti d'événements que
pour finalement il y arrive un singe
puis finalement il arrive un non
événement qui fait que le fais je laisse
de boucler ya besoin d'utiliser un petit
peu plus son cerveau pour survivre que
l'intelligence arrive que l'on utilise
des outils ils ont créé des technologies
je pense que cette infinité de hasard le
est infiniment rare que ça arrive
pratiquement jamais pas la vie mais la
vie intelligente et l'utilisation je
pense que c'est ces saignements
excessivement ouais mais ce que je peux
wipikit elle
il ya eu aussi les dinosaures sont
apparus sont disparus c'est quand même
important dans l'histoire parce que les
petits mammifères ils paient pas de mine
mais c'était de regarder des livres
d'innocents jambes
beaucoup ces temps ci les petits
mammifères en temps des dinosaures je te
jure qu'il dominait pas la planète petit
mulot qui la transcende sa politique
dans ton nom c'est pas un autre puis il
serait resté le packing l'ossétie avait
pas eu en partie le fameux oui c'est
cela la fameuse impact le avec un
astéroïde une comète loto québec qui ont
rendu la terre pas mal moins habitable
pendant un méchant bout de temps pour
lily gros reptiles mais mes ouailles se
fait maintenant mais tant qu'on prend
c'est la théorie le point qu'on dit
mettons qu'il ya une infinité de
possibilités mais il y aussi est
pratiquement une infinité de planète
puis elle met donc à y qui se prendre
une autre direction qui amène à une
chaîne d'improbabilité ou de hasard mais
dans une autre direction complète ça
veut pas dire qu'ils auraient non plus
au bout de tissu une autre sorte de vie
intelligente
c'est vrai que maintenant ça veut pas
dire que parce qu'il prégnant y compris
de l'autre côté il se sait peut-être pas
l'homme mais mettons que dans un
contexte très beaux déguisements et mais
juste l'intelligence mais temps mais moi
je pense qu'au bout d'un autre y irait
pas possiblement ouais on le voit les
foires scientifiques sciences et comme
souvent c'est comme du genre de
dinosaure dans une barre d'une planète
qui parce que à un jour est arrivé ce
serait vraiment plus chaudes
ça serait du monde au sang froid tu sais
peut-être évoluer intelligemment mais
tombé mais tant que la planète était
plus chaude puis qu'il y aurait voulu
que ce soit les reptiles la place des
mammifères qui est connu et il n'y avait
pas eu la fameuse astéroïde justement
peut-être que ça serait dit une seule
dans une odeur qui avait eu besoin
d'intelligence pour survivre sarreyer
révolue et de fermes en mai puis
deuxième hypothèse je pense que quand ça
arrive
l'intelligence ben je pense qu'il n'est
pas seulement je pense qu'on va
s'autodétruire puis à vendre que des
menaces peu avant d'explorer toute la
galaxie
je pense qu'ils ont juste comme
s'éteindre qui les civilisations sont
pas capables de se rendre jusque ce
point est le sens de venir être mais
c'est vraiment des bonnes cependant
depuis dans mon fameux livre il ya comme
trois sections plus tu viens de décrire
comme tout toutes les hypothèses d'une
des sections
c'est à dire que on est on est seul pour
plein de raisons on est seul parce que
c'était super dur de se rendre leurs
actes et dans le fond me tombe
une des solutions si le passage de la
vie unicellulaires à la vie
multicellulaire est extrêmement rare et
une conception qui je sais pas moi mais
tout tout tout ce que tu décris dans le
fond toutes les petites transitions puis
moi j'ai lu un autre livre ça fait
vraiment longtemps que ça m'avait
vraiment comme oh mon dieu ça s'appelle
runs cédé dans le fond deux
scientifiques qui ont écrit sur des
années 90 puis ça explique exactement ce
que tu genre c'est on n'est pas parce
qu'il ya eu comme une période dans les
années 60 où on était comme convaincu je
sais pas il y avait comme un optimiste
dans l'eure là tout le monde était
convaincu qu'il y avait de la vie
partout le petit monde à croire qu'ils
ont fait le cdh si on va chercher de la
vie comme on était vraiment motivé
puis moi je pense que je le vois comme
ça plus comme des années 90 aujourd'hui
peut-être pour finalement c'est là que
se livrent le était écrit le la très
rare ce que le français ou est-ce que ça
explique qu'effectivement il ya comme
une succession de hasards qui nous ont
menés jusque là qui qui sont vraiment
pas évident qu'ils vont arriver mais
mettant un bon point aussi vachers qui y
est et on on sait pas si on avait pris
une autre voie
si ça même paul e
mais ça c'est une autre dd hypothèse
c'est que l'intelligence n'est pas
inévitable
c'est si tu peux dominer la planète en
est en jeu c'est pour moi le plus gros
le plus méchant celui qui a le plus
directement les t-rex
mais peut-être que t'es pas besoin de
développer l'intelligence en tout cas il
ya des recherches qui sont là dessus
pour savoir à quel point c'était
vraiment un avantage puis après ben si
c'est un super bon point ce cette
intelligence le témoin des fois quand
suite des présentations secondaire
j'ai dit que la terre c'est la seule que
la vie est-il jambes je mets toujours
une photo donald trump a dû mettre une
photo dans le tram puis une autre d'une
usine qui rejette balles et des gaz pour
dire que c'est la vie qu'on qualifie
nous de intelligente le kickoff com
ligne de classe i fenger qu'avec celles
dites il ya peut-être des intérêts ce
qui viennent site caterpillar ont non
audité du gentil mais il ya toute une
section du livre qui est aussi sceptique
et comme you de la vie intelligente mais
on la voit pas pour toutes sortes de
raisons puis il ya des scénarios comme
plus loufoques qui sont un peu comme y
attendent qu'on évolue genre stade plus
pour rentrer dans les clous d'un truc
c'est ça c'est inquiétant qui finissent
par inventer l'espèce de web drive
justement pour aller plus vite et
vitesse lumière
c'est là que toutes les autres
civilisations rentrent en contact qu'il
ne vous ai pas parlé mais ça me motive
moi je passe pas je pense tout se passe
extrêmement rare je pense pas qu'on ait
un seul parce qu'encore lui est encore
un peu la vision et chrétienne de
jordanie est spéciale mais tu aimais
tant qu'un de trois civilisations dans
la galaxie méthane étaient les chances
qu'on envoyait un autre centre ils sont
régalés j'avais vu une image montre mais
vraiment marquer si mon superviseur de
maîtrise s'appelle robert lamontagne
c'est un super bon vulgarisateur ça
notre officier aussi je te dit à l'ats
thomas prendriez dallas tout le monde en
parle de beaune qui lui il y fait
beaucoup beaucoup de conférences grand
public puis il s'est il montré serein
l'image de la voie lactée c'est la voie
lactée ça à peu près cent mille années
lumière d'un bord à l'autre de diamètre
il montre il y aura y ajouter des
cercles dessus de différentes grosseurs
pour montrer des civilisations de
différent qui qui qui serait apparue à
différents moments fait plus le cercle
est grand plus ça fait longtemps que la
civilisation est apparu plus ça fait
longtemps qu'elle émet des signaux puis
bombay et sur sas à son image mais ça va
fasciner et images à lire montré après
parce que je trouve ça trop cole s'est
tu vois nous on et puis on a un tout
petit tout petit tout petit cercle de
jeu demandé sans eau ni lumière de
chaque côté d'enquêté large de 200
années lumière à peu près puis peut-être
quand un autre mais elle sait être 600
années-lumière puis ça fait cinquante
d'années lumière c'est ça fait cinquante
années qu'elle existe il y en a
peut-être un autre de leur barda galaxy
qui est arrivé il ya vraiment plus
longtemps mais justement il se sont auto
détruit en mai mais la variété comme
guerre nucléaire ou bains et pollution
et et y ont détruit leur civilisation
bâché pas quoi il est arrivé une comique
qui est le coeur brisé leur situation
fait que ce illustrait comme au lieu
d'être un cirque plans illustrés comme
un genre de beignes fait qu'il y aurait
émis pendant un certain temps mais à
partir d'un certain moment ils ont
arrêté puis tu voyais que selon à quel
point ya en europe c'est on peut faire
des calculs selon ce qu'on pense qui est
vraiment le sait peu mais il ya des
chances que ce qui est une autre
civilisation qui recoupe la note ou peu
ça m'avait vraiment frappé petit parlant
de civilisation qui s'écroule j'écoutais
moi j'ai eu un peu de casse kg coûte que
j'adore qui s'appelle d astronomie caste
en anglais ou le ya deux personnes qui
j'ose d'astronomie depuis à présent
depuis toujours je vois ça fait dix ans
donc leur podcast rôle même parce que ça
fait super longtemps puis si j'écoutais
l'astrophysicienne qui parlait puis à 10
et puis elle me faisait réaliser
elle est ici aujourd'hui avec quelque
chose qui détruisait notre civilisation
jeu c'est pas mon genre
inspiré d'un accord juste et ce qu'on se
comprenne par rapport à l'environnement
tai chi kung dans le fond la
civilisation était un peu c'est comme on
perdre un peu la civilisation
reconstruire la civilisation aujourd'hui
from scratch et c'est à partir de thons
du niveau survie une intrigante imagine
une apocalypse lot il ya beaucoup de
firmes ne va pas dire que tout les
humains seraient éliminés le testu ça
serait dur d'éliminer toutes les morts
les moto qui en reste ayant un sens
certain nombre pi bon puis que la
planète est encore habitable ça serait
vraiment pas évident de refaire la
civilisation parce que nous on a profité
de genre les combustibles fossiles
n'existe plus on les eaux consommées
ccoty bleus on a utilisé des matériaux
ces jeux c'est pas juste ne serait-ce
que le faire l'année de toutes les
matériaux qu'on utilise pour faire tout
le t il construire nos villes construire
nos nos équipements ils sont pas faciles
à aller chercher le fait que supposé
manquons encore les connaissances avec
les connaissances ont peu été éliminés
mais ça serait vraiment pas évidente et
parce que tu peux pas facilement aller
par exemple drilles et pour aller
chercher de l'huile dans des plateformes
offshore
c'est pas quelque chose que tu peux voir
quand et comme en mode survie lé fait
que j'ai acheté comme un vrai que c'est
vrai un effectif pour avoir une
civilisation qui était vraiment comme
support avancé mais pour plein de
raisons qui a perdu ses moyens
puis qui peut pas parce que les
ressources facilement accessibles de sa
planète autant au niveau énergétique que
de matériel ils sont pas faciles d'accès
il y avait une nouvelle que j'avais lu
abandonné qui m'avait fasciné le site
est à la base d isaac asimov qui avait
écrit ce nouvel os mais à le comité est
tendue dans un livre demain que c'est un
livre cool que ça venait chercher
terrain des concepts ou je sais pas si
vous savez que
notre soleil c'est une étoile qui comme
tout seul mais dans la galaxie ya
vraiment beaucoup des toiles qui
viennent parfaire des étoiles binaires
qu'on appelle donc tous les étoiles il
tourne qui non seulement ça existe les
étoiles binaires mais en fait on connaît
un des planètes qui sont le plus genre
tatouine wow et qui ont dû le soleil ou
qui ont 3 soleil parce que c'est ça ça
existe aussi des systèmes triple
effectuée l'automne deux étoiles qui se
tournent autour suite à une autre qui
tourne autour de la peur mais ça se peut
aussi plus récemment lui ont découvert
un système bixi ses toiles avec qui je
sais pas si vous avez entendu je vous ai
jamais dormir ne pas prendre mon genou
mais si nous mais c'est certes il y
avait une série battlestar galactica
cesser ces geeks
j'ai vraiment aimé sopi quand celles
faisant un petit peu de recherche à
savoir c'est quoi leur système originel
tu voyais que c'est un système avec
plein des toiles comme ça avec des
planètes autour de chacun fait dans la
nouvelle je pense qu'ils s'appellent
night for mais justement imaginer une
planète qui était dans un système avec
beaucoup trop de soleil je pense que je
me suis un peu cité 4 ou 6 puis donc la
nuit ne tombait jamais ou presque sauf
dans une certaine configuration qui je
pense que ça arrivait comme à toutes les
6000 ou 7000 1 puis à chaque fois que ça
arrivait dans son la stylisation craché
est-ce quelqu'un vient cracher dans 106
crouler parce quelqu'un baille imagine
xt10 dûment noté qu telle mais comme
dans les psychés humaniste jamais vu la
nuit ces randonnées la nuit ce point
mais en fait oublier ça fait sept mille
ans et que l'adhérent janus est pointée
c'est peut-être une légende gens
attendent histoire mais le ca en fait ça
désorganise complètement que tout le
monde vire fou harper puis dans le fond
leur suffisent à c'est aussi à remarquer
cela c'est en soulignant que j'avais
matri pas la drire là dessus puis ça
amène un peu l'idée aussi d'un autre
explication du paradoxe de fermi c'est
comme si si c'est comme ça et
l'astronomie c'est pas une science
facilement
c'est une bonne nuit c'est comme quand
je regarde le ciel mon pendant le jour
le jeune spock des étoiles parce que le
soleil dans le fond il vient comme
celles diffusées dans l'atmosphère puis
ça fait dans le fond le ciel bbc qui ça
m'empêche de voir toutes les étoiles
fixes y avait peu de nuit moi je serais
je connaîtrais pas grand chose sur
l'astronomie tpiy si jamais une nuit sur
la terre on arrêtait moins curieux on
n'avait pas inventé le télescope qu'on
aurait moins de checchi vers le haut
pour trouver des réponses je sais pas
c'est un colleur en iran dans pure
spéculation mais pas prend quand ce
serait intéressant notre étoile mais
mettez une autre un autre affaire du
même genre on sait qu'ils existent des
membres qui sont couverts d'eau et 24
contre un catamaran bien s'y dérouler à
quoi mène ses citoyens non je pense pas
sous l'océan mais bref c'est une
jeudi nous ont un moment donné la vie on
pense qu'elle est apparue sous l'eau si
on pense qu est apparu dans les espèces
de volcans sous marins on n'a pas opposé
volkan mais on faisait des fumeurs noirs
qui sont comme des endroits dans le fond
d'océan où il ya des plaques technique
tectoniques qui qui se rencontrent pied
donc il ya de l'énergie puis un paquet
de matériaux qui sort de l'eau qui on
pense que c'est dans ce coin là que la
vie s'est formé mais ça a été un gros
pas pour l'humanité que pour l'humanité
pour la vie sur terre que cette ville au
sortent de l'eau mais c'était une
planète qui oppose de terre évidemment
la vie sortira jamais de l'eau ça veut
pas dire qu'elle va pas se complexifier
pilon c'est là sur terre il ya des
espèces de vie qui sont très avancés qui
vivent dans l'aube et là on pense aux
dauphins mais les dauphins c'est de même
faire fait que la mondanité sur terre et
qui sont tournés ouais ouais ouais ok
près marche à deux pattes
ouais ça c'est ça
mais en fait non non c'est comme la
baleine voie la plus grosse aussi du
marché j'avoue je sais pas quel moment
la caisse cette heure-ci kelly mort
c'est comme retourner dans la rue m on
pense pas que ce serait comme impossible
qui se dit qu'il ya ça devienne très
évolué très avancé pid
d'ailleurs on parle souvent des lunes de
jupiter saturne
on est bien excité parce les lunes de
jupiter et saturne si c'est entre autres
parce qu'il ya des océans d'eau liquide
plus ou moins profondes en dessous de la
surface puis on est copains de l'eau
liquide peut-être que la vie que s'est
développée là aussi on sait qu'on est
capables d'y aller c'est loin mais on
peut aller le thé dans le fond me
parlait beaucoup de l'étude des
civilisations mettons dans sous d'autres
systèmes dans la galaxie mais mettons
dans notre propre système solaire
on peut imaginer que c'est possible
qu'il y ait des formes de vie huawei
tout à fait tout à fait oui c'est clair
mais je veux juste finir ce qu'elle
faisait avec la moto et une vie était
jambes soul devenir une civilisation tu
voyages dans l'espace ça serait quand
même neuf mois c'est premièrement ben
observées ici elle serait vraiment
compliqué puis deuxièmement c'est amener
tout en haut avec toi entre le lot c'est
lourd fait que c'est juste fin de la
parenthèse mais oui allons le dans notre
système solaire
et ça ça fait pas si longtemps que ça
c'est qu'on est pas mal sûr qu'il ya pas
genre d'autres civilisations dans notre
système solaire jusqu'à temps qu'on
m'envoie des sondes vers mars était au
milieu du xxème siècle il y en a encore
qui fabule est le qui avait des choses
c'est je pense qu'à la fin du 19e ou est
ce qu'il y avait un astronome qui avait
dessiné la surface de mars puis l'enfant
il ya plein de structures la surface de
mars ses yeux comme des défauts et puis
et qui avait dessiné ça lui avait appelé
cdd qu'analyste en italien puis après
quand ça a été quand ça circuler cette
information là il y en a qui pensait
rester
des canaux mais dans ce que nous sommes
je pense qu'on je suis pas en français
ce qui annonça implique automatiquement
vie intelligente genre cannes des canaux
construite par l'homme mais dans ce
temps là aussi est en train de
construire des grands canaux ces genres
les le canal de suez ce qui permet de
voyager hors de la mer méditerranée en
egypte le fait que c'est vraiment dans
l'imaginaire collectif que des canaux
s'est construit par des citations
intelligent fait qu'il y avait vraiment
des gens qui étaient convaincus que
c'est une civilisation intelligente qui
qui construisaient des canaux pour
transmettre dans le fond là le l'eau
sous forme de glace sur l'épaule pour
les transmettre sur toute la planète le
fait que c'est ça fait vraiment pas si
longtemps mais maintenant sur mars corey
loi si je me trompe cech mars puis on
voit que à une certaine époque dans le
passé il y avait de l'eau à sa surface
parce qu'on voit des rivières on voit
des aspérités des lits des rivières et
des lits de rivières et qu'on se dit fut
un temps où il y avait de l'eau leur ai
fait les vélos liquide puis à date qu'on
sait pas ce qu'on se dit assuretat
wasquehal où il ya de la vie mais
peut-être que jadis il y avait mis bis
de la vie sur mars paraître ouais ouais
ouais c'est pas cessé pour farfelu
pensée se maintenant on sait pas faire
fait lui mais là on n'est pas en train
de parler de martiens sommes en train de
construire des liens double t on n'est
plus en train de parler de forme des
vies très simples comme y avait dans le
fond au début sur terre laurent marck b
ya encore une possibilité que ces
espèces bcs parce que cette ville soit
est protégée sous terre dans le fond
qu'est ce que vivent loin dans peut-être
des grottes aussi pas évident l'hôte et
on a pu tant d'espoirs que ce soit de
trouver des choses très complexe mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il n'a pas le métier on
a quand même envoyé des des lander des
atterrisseurs sur mars quand même pas
mal on en maintenant on envoie des
rovers des astros mobile sur mars y en a
un qui vient juste de partir qui va
arriver comme les 18 février le
surveiller
puis on prend des symboles de roche
ouais on les tchèques ouaip y attendons
vos petites unités on voit rien qui
bouge fait que ce qu'ils cherchent
présentement puisque ses missions le
sont conçus pour faire céder des traces
des des signes indirects et des bons la
vie quand qui est présente à modifie
l'environnement de certaines façons donc
essayer de trouver le genre de faux
selon guy mais facile mais comme un peu
chimiques vous des commandes commente la
vie affecté au niveau genre moléculaire
puis atomique
la surface on ne peut pas complètement
perdu espoir qui rit est peut-être des
formes de vie même encore aujourd'hui
mais c'est pas une chance très très très
forte mais on conçoit encore des
missions le qui nous permet de répondre
à cette question là c'est vraiment une
planète qui était comme explorer le
vraiment beaucoup le ton a mis beaucoup
d'énergie pour explorer cette planète
rap c'est pas pour rien et est une
planète qui est assez proche de la terre
puis qu'il ya des similitudes mais il ya
quand même beaucoup de différence puis
il ya encore de l'eau au pôle qui est
glacée comme ça à de la glace est ce
possible qu'ils aient sous taille avec
des rivières d'eau courante ou c'est
impossible est une bonne question que se
posent d'après moi c'est c'est pas
impossible mais c'est pas super probable
puis mettons il y avait une certaine
époque dans le fond mars avec
l'atmosphère c'est pour ceux qui avaient
de l'eau blunt qui a encore une
atmosphère sur mars mais c'est juste
qu'est vraiment pour danser parce que
mars est vraiment plus petite la terre
le diffon s'imaginent que c'est un monde
vraiment mais c'est ici c'est quand même
petit le mars c'est à peu près je me
suis mis sa moitié du lac de la grosseur
de leur fixer quand même petit puis à
cause de sauter c'est pas capable de
retenir une atmosphère aussi dans en
plus l'atmosphère semble pas vraiment
ici le surtout c'est surtout du dioxyde
de carbone fait vraiment peur respirable
mai
mais ma question c'est est ce que c'est
que c'est passé sur mars pour qui tout
d'un coup le losc s'en aille mais l'eau
s'est pas en aller mais a subi this sous
forme mais je pense que c'est aussi lié
au fait que la planète a évolué du fait
de sa petite taille perdu son atmosphère
effectivement le canto presque puis
d'atmosphère bello peu ça va s'évaporer
mais il y en a peu qui subsistent pire
est l'atmosphère leçon mars mais c'est
pas ce pas une atmosphère ici on parle
par exemple d'envoyer des astronautes
sur mars mais il faut les protéger et et
parce que genre les rayons uv ira entre
le web et les rayons cosmiques qui
arrivent de partout dans l'univers le
fait que si bonne place aux monnaies ont
des proches commandants oui du monde
sont morts ça dépend qui demande une
mode qui dirait on est près leurs idoles
et à des personnes s'est enthousiasmé
dans entre autres dans l'industrie
privée qui qui aimerait ça que ce soit
comme demain matin est il bon lit je
veux pas discuter de démotivation du
losc est un personnage assez sérieux à
mon sens le même mais bon il est très
certainement très fortement la volonté
d'explorer mais lui veut comme qu'elle à
l'humanité soit sur deux planètes
oliveux conçoit pas sûr juste une
planète parce qu'il trouve ça dangereux
fait que ça serait comme dans la ligue
prochain 10 15 ans le timon quand je
vais visiter des jeunes aux primaires je
leur disais que ça serait tout à
l'astronaute qui va aller sur mars le
métayer quand même une grosse différence
en envoyer des astronautes pour explorer
puis au loyer nos colonies les api la
colonie est encore totalement des dandys
c'est plus c'est pas vraiment dans des
plans concrets de d'exploration ni du
public ni du privé mais dans un monde
pas imaginable dans un monde où est-ce
qu'on a l'air technologie est ce que
c'est possible de transformer mars une
place habitants
ça c'est que c'est une des phrases
affaire qui m'ont intéressé quand je me
suis quand je pense qu je sais pas ça
fait super longtemps que j'ai je lis la
tulle la terraformation de mars s'est
invitée au marché c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle genre changer une planète pour
la mettre à nos goûts bon le côté
éthique de ça on peut en parler d'abord
parlé de la mentalité que les zattere
pourquoi j'ai surtout s'ils ont un peu
plus oui la vip non mais ça c'est super
important j'ai lu la première nation
depuis j'ai lu récemment une série de bd
qui s'appelle les mondes d'aldébaran
c'est vous lirez ceci nous aimer la
science fiction c'est écrit par un
français puis un autre et l'hypothèse ça
a été écrit des années 90 ça paraisse a
été écrit avant que les premières
exoplanètes soit détectée quand qu ils
vont vers des planètes qui ressemble en
tout point à la trêve c'est vraiment
drôle mais non le sait que les
exoplanètes en tout cas il ya tellement
de grandes variétés qui trouvaient des
jumelles de la terre le gmail gmail
avoir quelques mois être priées de
grosseur de genre de questions dans
l'atmosphère ça serait pas aussi
plausible que ça mais bref
yvon pillion toujours la règle qui
peuvent pas établir si une espèce qui
genre intelligente des jeux le met déjà
en partant si de la vie tout court
est-ce que c'est correct d'aller lopy
d'amener nos affaires puis de peut-être
menacé cette ville qui disait que les
gens football intelligente pas pisser
des geôles côté il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de réflexion qui se fait là dessus pour
maintenant le par rapport aux quand on
envoie le son d'un instrument des loups
quelque chose c'est possible de se
désinfecter jeudi d'enlever ces
bactéries mais pas ses pas et roule le
nombre de micro organismes sur toutes
les limites le monsieur n'a toujours
marqué 99 9% des tarifs qui vont rester
un point mort c'est exact mais tout est
affaire ils sont toujours consultés dans
des sales blancs
cela des endroits on a noté des endroits
où est-ce que c'est extrêmement
extrêmement crop le titre peut pas
rentrer leur en prendre une douche je
suis pas de crever de là dedans non mais
mais mais ça reste que t on à chaque
fois qu'on en voyait des choses sur mars
il est quand même une chance quand même
d'accord de terminer ses skis et ski
délicat puis problématique aussi c'est
que le site envoie une mission qui vise
à détecter de la vie présente ou
ancienne bête toujours le problème de
coûts dont tu veux être en train de
texter tt propre micro organismes qui
est emmené chez vous surtout ce qu'ils
s'étaient rendus à un point qui est du
detec des traces gimmick du genre
quelque chose de vraiment vraiment
baiser claudine de base il a là c'est
vraiment pas évident comme problème qui
fait quoi aimer mais présentement c'est
ce qu'ils font le la mission qui a été
envoyée parce que l'enfant sur pour mars
il ya eu une série de missions qui sont
avait à peu près toutes les deux ans
quand la planète à passe vraiment proche
de la terre sont plus proches parce que
tu es d'envoi les deux tournent autour
il ya des moments que c'est vraiment des
bombes des bonne fenêtre de lancement
puis il y en a une qui vient juste de se
produire le je pensais au début de
l'automne si je me trompe pas puis donc
il va y avoir plusieurs trucs qui vont
arriver sur mars bientôt parce que ça
prend un certain nombre de semaines
avant de se rendre sur cet article
puis il ya justement un gros instrument
biel qui va se poser de la nasa qui va
commencer à
je pense appel persévérance les
américains sont comme pas capable de
dire c'est un mot le mandat dont il
s'appelle persévérance puis ils font
entre autres faire des expériences pour
essayer de voir s'ils répondent des
traces des vignes et il pense à ces
problèmes le met dans les première chose
qu'ils ont envoyés sur mars je pense le
premier qui a atterri avec succès et
c'était 2 semble s'appeler les vikings
d'une des dettes l'esprit des américains
exploration du système cela mais les
vikings il y avait des expériences pour
vérifier s'il y avait de la vie
pigboss était un conclusif le y en a
encore pour être convaincu je pense
qu'elle comme une des quatre expériences
qui disait que la vie mais tu es si on
avait eu dans ce lot il résulte détectés
ailleurs et que bon la plupart pensent
que c'est un faux positif le
l'expérience que mais bon c'est pas
impossible aussi qu'on ait manqué
quelque chose quelque chose qu'on
comprend pas pis ça c'était dans les
années 70 déjà qu'on qu'on essayait de
voir s'ils avaient pas des traces de vie
sur mars puis l'autre partie de la
question initialement c'était aussi de
savoir est-ce qu'on a la technologie
pour je pense que ce que tu disais
terrifie sierra d informer mars avec
méthode qu'une fois qu'on arrive là
qu'on dit que le point de vue éthique
c'est correct là il n'y a pas de vie sur
mars
on y va qu'est-ce que
demain qu'on procède je pense que en
science fiction les gens qui ont exploré
sa abondamment mais je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de vraie façon qui permettrait
vraiment dit de rentrer toute la planète
la bosse un sou depuis respirer d'un
sachs à se piquer ça consisterait meute
on sait des choses sont vraiment le un
peu comme ici sur terre quand on parle
de changer la concentration des en
séquestrant des ghosts ici un peu allez
avoir une influence sur la planète que
nous conclut mme c'est pas évident le
mais je pense que ça implique c'est de
faire fondre les calottes polaires pour
avoir plus de gars à augmenter comme
cela l'élève la pression atmosphérique
c'est la quantité d'or ce qui est dans
l'atmosphère maisons et les arbres
plantés d'ici quand êtes-vous beaucoup
de jeunes mais joyeux c'est justement
dans une potentielle colonisation sur
marty c c'est quoi le but c'est
premièrement ils m'ont demandé ce que ça
coûterait une fortune squale but
clotilde et comme aurait peut-être que
ça nous permettrait d'éliminer les
astéroïdes plus facilement mais
probablement qui est ici y avait du
commerce au début entre la terre puis
mars mais probablement genre que le
fumier serait quelque chose très très
très en demande donc dans une colonie
juive est vachement content parce que le
seul présentement sur marcy super
toxiques théière il ya des processus
chimiques qui se font entre ce qui est à
la surface puis les rayons uv qui sait
ça c'est toxique c'est toxique pour
presque toute la vie telle qu'on la
connaît même très simple en surface
l'excellent ne vais pas faire pousser
nos patates but ici le but de
l'opération 6 mettons ce assurer notre
survie de mettons une autodestruction
sur la terre sont là le technologie pour
terraformer mars en hausse ma
technologie poe mais la changement
climatique ici même si c'est vraiment
compliqué 3 une place folle king in
australia pile à la tournée en temps
exactement c'est ça je le dis souvent
c'est comme il y en a et plus jeune ma
demande a été il ya une petite confusion
tant astronomes puis astronautes c'est
donc il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
maintenant à têtu déjà allé dans
l'espace et aimerait tous aller dans
l'espace jeux comme je ne peux pas c'est
faudrait que je fasse comme les prêts
ning d'astronomie et y en aura des
astronautes qui ont des formations en
astrophysique à la basse puis en a qui
ont des formations d'autres choses en
biologie ou même qu'ils sont comme des
pilotes de l'armée mais mais moi j'ai
paul traîner astronomes mais ils me
demandent certaines red sox comme
sincèrement pas vraiment du genre la
planète très flou c'est vraiment une
paupière place dont m puis j'aimerais
mieux rester ici c'est comme toutes les
places sur terre sont plus habitables
que mars était des fois on imagine mars
journée commence à s'installer là-bas
pour nom le l'antarctique et plus
habitable que plus exact l'exacte copie
mais c'est ça mais mars le seuil est
loin il n'y a pas d'heure ils rêvent
traite tout il ya comme plein d'affaires
qui sont dangereuses pour toi c'est la
même chose pour la lune c'est la même
chose pour l'espace attenant l'espace le
sait pas donc c'est super je le sais on
l'a vu avec les films de genre gravité
comme on parle d'un entretien ce qu'ils
sont gentils mais mais ça permet
d'explorer d'aider des trucs en
préparation en suisse ont justement je
crois un des films de science-fiction
voit ce que la science la plus accrue
etc de marché notamment
ouais ouais c'est reconnu comme tel dans
nos têtes dans notre milieu il ya je
pense
et évidemment il ya des gens qui
s'amusent à chercher les harengs les
bibittes le puits ces projets coûtent et
podcasts juste à maintenir degrasse
tyson ou sql legault qui a écrit ce
livre parce que c'est bon à ce rallye il
parlait qui il était par exemple une des
choses qui peuvent vrai c'est qu'elle
attend pas de sobres et la tempête qui
fait que matt damon res prix sûrement ce
mets ton juste pour les gens qui
écoutent qui ont aucune de ces coins là
l'enfant matt damon hill paniers sont
mars pisser de survivre sexy comme
toutes les méthodes pour
essayer de se débrouiller sur mass mech
cérémonie n'a pas de sens et une tempête
de sable puis on le sait qu'il ya des
tempêtes de sable sur mars est vrai qu'à
des tempêtes de sable qui sont comme
epic ses pendants plusieurs je sais même
pas combien de temps ça dure mais pas
vraiment longtemps il peut y avoir comme
un genre d elise le nom en anglais parce
que c'est comme ça devienne première
nous autres on perd on perd le contact
avec nous six robots sur mars
les panneaux solaires deviennent sa
cible
sauf que les vins s'est produit 20 qui
ferait voler les choses parce qu'elle y
sommes pas des routes risque c'est que
c'est ce qu'ils disent est le levain il
ferait même pas voler un drapeau le fait
que ses pas il pourrait y avoir une
tempête genre que tu es dedans tu es
comme ceux boîte branchée bras mais le
lautaret je le savais mais je m'en fous
il vit dans le temps la quantité demande
ce qu'ils lisaient mon livre puis qui
faisait comme qui avait les
connaissances nécessaires pour dire ça
se peut pas mais je voudrais y était
quand même près on apaise le suspense ne
décevez l'image et je suspends mom amont
des crises bill m'ont écrit parce que je
mets mes bref et si tu lis la
science-fiction tu acceptes ya certaines
choses qui se paumer été comme me l'a
appris et c'est là tout le monde était
tout le monde notamment trippé sur le
martien qui tout le monde ne peut pas
faire le jeu mais c'est que ça reste ça
reste la science fiction mais tease et
qu'elle est vraiment fait super
attention pour que tout soit pas mal
réaliste qui tue c'est vrai que c'est un
peu la prochaine étape le thé dans la
conquête l'exploration spatiale pour
l'humanité c'est pas c'est pas comme
interstellaire look voyages on y
trouvera pour aller vers des exoplanètes
ont des trous noirs
qu'est ce que c'est que j'aurais perdu
juste l'idée de walk on peut voyager
d'appui arrivée lobée de ce constat
comment c'est de la physique vraiment
exotiques l'été c'est non c'est ça c'est
pas c'est pas comme aux mondiaux c'est
dur d'envoyer des humains sur mars parce
que le voyage dure longtemps et les
rayons cosmiques pour être dangereux
pour leur genre et pour avoir plus de
chances d'avoir des cancers ça c'est un
vrai problème concret est difficile
qu'il faut résoudre avant d'aller sur
mars et mai mais le litre ou de mon dieu
non le sujet même pas marc l'adage dans
la liste de choses que je sais pas
reconnue comme étant une façon de
voyager non c'est ça c'est ça puis moi
c'est ça j'avais aimé interstellaire
parce que je trouvais ça cool de ces
comme je pouvais arriver sur une planète
aussi house qu'il va gaiement sur ce
super cool qui oscillait l'idée du temps
qui changent le met mais j'avais peau et
messieurs pour l'aspect environnemental
la chose parce que avec je pense tout le
monde est rendu un peu plus sensible à
ce mes nous aurons en astronomie avec
notre point de vue qu'on a sur la terre
t on est comme il l'a l'artiste qu'une
planète c'est fragile
comment je sois bien on est tous dans le
même bateau l'effectif la manière de
voir la terre de notre officier c'est
vraiment comme ces fragiles ces précieux
donc ça arrive souvent que des grand
astrophysicien c'est par exemple hubert
reeves ils deviennent très très très
actif le haut niveau de la cause
environnementale parce qu'ils la rareté
de ce qu on a exactement pitt et moi
puis mes collègues en aidant on est dans
cette dynamique le titre vient juste
d'écrire avec une de mes collègues white
people
comment qu'on appelle ça un en france et
c'est juste comme un un point de vue que
en tant que communauté astronomique au
canada c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'il faut penser un dock bref quand tu
vois si tu dis il l'a la ccc fragile
pileux
dans le film c'est comme ou un bain la
planète avait peu habitable c'est un peu
plate mais on va s'en trouvera de back
up
finalement il ya comme un une histoire
que je veux pas donner du punch pudeur
je me souviens plus des détails mais
mais qui allait pas déménager 7
milliards de tata mais quand même ça
donne un peu feeling de genre savate off
mais on va réussir
mais non ça va pas être top qu'on va
résoudre via un impôt de plan b comme
fait attention à la planète il ya po 2
de back up qui ont seuls fait souvent
demandé aux autres comment allez-vous
chercher les genres des exoplanètes
comme des ménages et le match comme non
non vraiment pas on essaie de mieux
comprendre à quel point notre planète
est comme unique piccoli espérerait la
matière on essaie de mieux comprendre
tout court le titre c'est juste la
science on essaie d'en apprendre plus
sur l'univers on n'est pas en train de
se chercher un back up non non mais j'ai
jamais j'allais continuer notre survol
du système solaire que l'on parle
beaucoup de mars
ouais mais il yad'autres place un
système soir là où est ce que c'est
possible qu'on retrouve la vie ouais il
ya des places arrière quand on pense que
c'est plus plausible
donc il ya de la vie encore aujourd'hui
jean europe europa ouais c'est dans le
fond dans notre système solaire il ya
deux des quatre planètes géantes puis en
a deux qui sont plus grosse crise oc
jupiter saturne jupiter est plus proche
de nous puis saturne est un petit peu
plus loin puis ces deux planètes l'oeil
ont beaucoup de l'une des lunes peas et
des fois on est en train de travailler
sur un projet sur justement les lunes
pour l'agencé spatiale canadienne qui on
réalise pas à quel point une lune c'est
quand même c'est un monde le sait c'est
pas juste une petite affaire bosch qui
tourne autour de nos hôtes leur tice et
il ya des dizaines de lune autour de
jules table saturn qui en a plusieurs
parmi celles qui sont significativement
grosse il ya deux lunes une hauteur de
jetable une autour de saturne qui sont
plus grosses que mercure dont qui sont
plus t'as pas besoin d'être plus petit
qu'une planète pour être qualifié d' une
lune de juste besoin de tourner autour
de quelque chose d'autre qu'une étoile
fait que dans le fond c'est des membres
céder petit monde à part entière et puis
justement est heureux d'enfants autour
de jupiter
essentiellement il ya comme 4 grosse
lune les autres sont intéressantes mais
ses portes et c'est pas aussi limit no
comment puis les quatre grosses lune
sont toutes super intéressante mais une
en particulier dont on parle souvent ces
europe où est repassé en france on du
repas entre europe inquiète comme un
espèce de petit on appelle ça des
satellites de glace parce que justement
il ya comme plein plein plein de glace
à l'extérieur puis c'est lui le bain ils
se font réchauffer par effet de marie
qu'on appelle donc le fait qu'ils
aillent une grosse planète jupiter
monotone à côté puis d'autres lunes
assez grosse ça fait qu'ils arrêtent pas
de se faire un peu bros et qui on le
sait est sur terre les marées sont créés
par la présence de la lune mais cela un
peu la même concept les la présence
d'une grosse planète la présence de
d'autres lunes saphique la planète à
bouge à ces tirs ça génère une activité
une activité géologique qui réchauffe
dans le fond les couches puisqu'il
permet d'avoir on est presque certain on
est certain je pense
ddd océan d'eau liquide même s'ils sont
loin parce qu'ils sont super loin du
soleil selon me réchauffer commentaire
ce fait réchauffer dans la zone
habitable je mets des guillemets puisque
sont trop loin exactement sur une place
qu on se dirait s'expliquer la ville oh
oui ça se peut qu'eads la ville parce
que de la chance joue exactement
exactement puis la chaleur est pas
époque réparé exactement puis tu fais
une parenthèse intéressante sur la zone
habitable cescom un concept que les
astrophysiciens ont défini qui comme la
fourchette de distance autour d'une
étoile où il fait pas trop chaud potro
fret pour que lou reste liquide en
anglais avec legault d'ilog zone comme
dans boucle d'or et les trois ours qui
aimait son griot pas trop chaud ni trop
froid
c'est vrai il ya des attractions
sacrifice le bourg du landeron mais bref
cette zone le ca a été défini il ya
quand même une vingtaine d'années puis
maintenant on se rend compte que c'est
un concept qui oui utile le thé dans le
sens que par exemple le soleil il sera
pas toujours de cette température-là
mondony va devenir plus chaud vers la
fin de sa vie puis bon et la zone qui va
être habitables mais à voir exclure la
terre un moment donné parce que il va il
va être de plus en plus chaud qui fait
qu'à un moment donné il d'entrée très
très longtemps j'aime bien rassurer les
enfants que ça arrive repos n'y a eu ni
à leur descendance proches genre
l'humanité va peut-être avoir évolué
ivre probablement vers quelque chose
d'autre
avant mais bref ils veuillent y avoir un
moment où est ce que cette zone m
tableau ce repas même place et aussi on
sait qu'il est dans l'univers il ya des
étoiles de toutes sortes de grosses
heures
le soleil les étoiles sont pas toutes la
même grosseur quel soleil la plupart des
étoiles en fait son plus petit que le
soleil et on appelle ça des naines
rouges des naines et m dans notre jargon
sont beaucoup plus petites donc pour
elle dans la zone habitable entre
guillemets encore de ces étoiles là il
faut être beaucoup plus proche
c'est nous autres la terre a fait autour
du soleil 1 365 jours et corps
la durée d'une amie tandis que pour une
naine rouge la zone habitable est plus
comme tu fais le tour de son étoile en
quelques dizaines de jours donc son
bouquet plus proche puisque c'est un
truc c'est intéressant de penser à ça
parce que pas mal toutes les france
presse presque tout tout tout les
planètes qu'on a trouvé les exoplanètes
dans d'autres systèmes solaires qui sont
dans la zone habitable
il tourne autour de naines rouges mais
ça entraîne une série d'autres problèmes
parce que quand tu es proche comme se
battent eux plus de d'activité de ton et
walt et des éruptions stellaire qui
envoyent plein de rayonnement qui est
beaucoup beaucoup de beaucoup d'autres
comme entre guillemets danger pour la
vie qui arrive
il ya un phénomène qui s'appelle le tide
hold up que ça veut dire d'enfants une
synchronisation de la période de
rotation sur elle-même et de la période
de révolution
ça fait que c'est toujours la même face
de la planète qui fait face à l'étoile
dont l'une est exactement comme la lune
avec les autres fait que donc toujours
un côté qui sait le jour puis un côté
que c'est la nuit puis peut-être un
petit web heures avec une zone pas pire
entre les deux mais le s que ça reste
habitat c'est parce que c'est dans la
zone habitable motion un bon chiffre
exact c'est quand que le concept de zone
habitable est intéressant mais moi je
trouve qu'ils très mal nommée clermont
fra plus touchés par la zone tempérée ou
je sais pas quoi j'ai des fois je
c'est aussi con c'est tellement pot de
colle à vie pour avoir l'air ailleurs
complètement différent dans des
contextes en 10 10 10 c'est ce que c'est
complètement différent qu'on puisse même
pas s'imaginer que il pourrait avoir de
la vie à une place qu'on penserait qui
ne répondent exactement un métier
nous optons france-eire quand même parce
que c'est un peu comme là ça serait un
peu compte de porc garder le métier
c'est logique de regarder l'heure en
premier mais il ya tellement de choses
qui peuvent influencer je me suis même
au début tu sais quand je faisais mes
études on parlait quand même aussi
beaucoup de on le sait pas quelle
atmosphère ces planètes le haut c'est
quand tu prends venus filateurs le sur
papier mais donc tu regardes leurs
rayons ils sont pas mal pas réalité ces
deux planètes à peu près la même
grosseur kitty venu c'est à peu près le
dans la zone et chaabi table ou en tout
cas au juste en dehors mais pas trop
loin de la zone habitable c'est pour
habitable pour les humains venus eux
même pas capable d'envoyer des genres
décembre qui survivent plus que quelques
heures à la surface ils sont écrasés
il ya des pluies d'acide sulfurique
c'est comme il fait vraiment vraiment
chaud ces genres la chose qui ressemble
plus à m'en faire exactement ac c'est
vraiment peu adaptée tous parce qu'il ya
un effet de serre qui s'est emballé sur
venus pour plein de raisons le type
archos de quel gosse qui a fait nos
l'atmosphère pee wee et un peu plus
propre et il ya plein de choses qui sont
arrimés ce fine tuning loti on ne
connaît pas pour les exoplanètes et nous
autres à l'institut recherches sur les
exoplanètes ce travail là on est pas l
unique moyen de chercheurs à 1006 par
actif le comme domaines de recherche
c'est au québec où on est on peut être
fier d'ailleurs été d'avoir plusieurs
des leaders si nous on est comme une
cinquantaine de chercheurs
on s'intéresse à savoir tirer il y
aurait toute la vie ailleurs dans une
vague notre façon de le faire c'est de
commencer à huy découvrir des
exoplanètes puis commence à étudier
l'atmosphère fait présentement c'est ça
qui se fait il ya plein de techniques
faciles qui peuvent nous aider à étudier
l'atmosphère des exoplanètes mais on
n'est pas du tout au point où est ce
qu'on peut faire genre t'es dit guéri la
moss fatigue comme excuse et la planète
vraiment pas vraiment pas fille autres
on pourrait en parler aussi là on était
dans nos l'union rempart les os il a des
façons de détecter des exoplanètes puis
c'est peu et on ne peu de temps les
formations que ce team sur ses membres
des fonds on voit des belles images le
genre dans des revues sur internet mais
ces dix représentations artistiques le
une autre des fois on est capable
d'avoir la taille au carré est peut-être
d'avoir une idée de la masse peut-être
le justement on est en train d'arriver
au point on est capable de faire des
analyses de leurs atmosphères et c'est
juste des données vous avez vous a pas
de photos donner vraiment pas de photos
puis on n'est pas proche en avoir le non
plus fait qu'ils ont un télescope
spatial sur lesquels on travaille
s'appelle le télescope spatial james
webb
des fois je vais voter non déclarés qui
ont entendu parler du télescope spatial
hubble
puis souvent les gens ont entendu parler
parce que c'était comme le dernier gros
télescope spatial qui a permis de faire
énormément découvert pitt en corse
contre toute attente en activité donc si
ça comme un plus révolutionné
l'astrophysique dans les dernières
années mais on s'attend que le télescope
spatial james webb vaut faire un peu la
même chose qui lui va être lancée à
l'halloween prochaine en ruines puis
avec ses télescopes le une des gros
seins des gros sujets qu'on veut étudier
le si vraiment les exoplanètes leur
atmosphère et j'étais un fake
bref pour venir à europe mettant le si
on si on creuse le pis on voit premier
mode ou la boule peut-être qu'ils ont
retrouvé quelque chose qui nagent le
détail d'un dieu qui m pim et on pense
tu que de notre vivant à nous on veut
détectés soit de la vie microbienne dans
notre système solaire où on va détecter
des signaux provenant penses tu que les
chances sont bonnes c'est quoi
maintenant on prenait ckac à toi
maintenant je pense me semble avoir déjà
entendu commun qui s'appelait taux
directeur la montagne semble déjà
entendue dire ce monsieur que de notre
viseur on trouverait ce et beaucoup de
monde et c'est le jeune homme en qui je
pense que c'est plus osé surtout qu'ils
étaient on a plusieurs éléments de notre
technologie
qui nous amène à ce point là on y est on
est vraiment avancer je jugerai pas
prête à dire une date puis ça dépend de
quelque chose sur lequel je n'ai pas de
contrôle c'est à dire est-ce qu'il y en
a de la vie ailleurs
souvent je pense qu'elle robert ce
qu'ils disent et s'il y a de la vie
ailleurs
on devrait être capable à détecter venez
vite parce qu'il ya justement toute
cette énergie lucky qui nous permettent
maintenant de le faire dit quand tu
penses que la première exoplanète qui
était confirmée et on se doute elle qui
avait des planètes autour des étoiles
qu'on voit dentelle mais on n'avait
jamais là qu'on n'avait jamais eu la
confirmation que c'était bien que parce
que mais une étoile c'est très très très
brillant c'est une autre les planètes de
notre système solaire des fois on les
voit nancy l'été avant noël on voyait
jointe à saturne sont vraiment être
pourquoi qui sont brillance parce qu'ils
réfléchissent la lumière du soleil
intrinsèquement sont pas aussi brillante
que ce bon dans certaines longueurs
d'onde louis lemay entre bref faites
mais ci dessus on se souvient des
distances astronomiques ses collègues
qui nous sépare des autres étoiles si tu
prends la séparation entre une planète
puis son étoile par rapport à la
distance qui nous qui nous en séparent
syrien le d'enfants qui sont collés une
sur l'ordre on utilise beaucoup
l'analogie du fort donc imaginer dans un
petit bateau quitte ou moins fort sur la
côte on facebook large été détecté une
planète autour d'une étoile c'est un
petit peu comme essayer de détecter une
petite luciole qui voleraient à quelques
centimètres de la lumière dans la forme
c'est vraiment dur puis comme une des
façons de le faire ce genre faire se le
cacher la lumière de les doigts mais pas
de la planète en bloc la lumière de
l'étoile de plein de façons différentes
mais c'est une prouesse technologique
qui a été fait uniquement dans les
années 90 mais moi j'aime ça veut dire
je veux dire j'avais jeté en saumon
hareng en 95
après oui c'est ça c'est on n'a pas eu
la confirmation avant les années 90 a en
effet retenu d'un autre vivent en suisse
est excitant de penser quand votre
peut-être détecté de la vie mais
reculons un petit peu le genre mes
parents m'ont cancale à l'école le il
savait pas aussi avait des exoplanètes
nous on le sait non seulement le sait
mais on a ri
un point où on en connaît tellement con
et y avoir de faire des statistiques
c'est plus juste genre à on a trouvé une
planète oui on a trouvé une planète en
1995 après c'est au tournant des années
2000 je pense qu on en connaissait même
pas une centaine ça a été super long
puis à moment denis ben on est content
on a construit des on a conçu des
missions qui visait juste à détecter des
planètes visitées le cas de la mission
kepler le récemment j'avais un jeune qui
me demandais pourquoi toutes les
exoplanètes rappelle kepler quelque
chose c'est paul cool mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup d'exemples année qui
s'appelle quelques pleurs quelque chose
parce que bon les étoiles les hôtels
manquer les noms qu'on leur donne cd
numéro de catalogue fait que souvent
titre le dialogue
l'astrophysicien mon ami pied lui bien
hendry bon hd avec des chiffres après
ben ça c'est le nom de plusieurs visites
web répit dans d'autres catalogues c'est
d'autre chose puis mais des fois c'est
quand tu étudié avec un nouveau
télescope des étoiles
tu peux décider que c'est la première
étoile qui s'observe doit l'appeler
comme si le tsl s'appelle qui à part de
l'appliquer pleure un puits kepler je
puis donc avec kepler qui a observé
vraiment beaucoup de des toiles pour
voir s'ils avaient pas des planètes
autour ben il y en a trouvé vraiment
beaucoup donc beaucoup de planètes qui
porte le nom ben en fait notre
convention c'est que quand on trouve une
exoplanète
au lieu de se casser la tête pour
trouver des noms de dieux grecs et
romains parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
amène au plénum notre cerveau là mais il
y en avait pas de transaction on leur
donne le nom d'art étoiles puis on
rajoute une petite lettre à côté si je
vous ai parlé un peu tantôt que ya
beaucoup de des toiles qui sont en pêche
côtiers qui sont comme dans des systèmes
triple puis ça ça fait longtemps qu'on
sait sur qui on avait des jeunes
notation pour ça c'est qu'on dise
émeutes ont acheté 200 s'adonnera grand
a majuscule ou agir un grand b majuscule
et il ya un exemple si proxima du
centaure jeudi c'est l'étoile la plus
proche mais proxima du centaure dans un
système triple qui à tourner autour
d'eux alpha du centaure grand a et alfa
du centaure granby qui sont une paire
qui se tournent autour mais pourquoi
proxima le plus grand c'est mais ce
parce qu'on savait pas qui était dans le
même système casque est vraiment loin
mais bref ça c'est notre système avec
lettres majuscules fait connaître au
québec pour laly planète
on n'utilisera pas dommage que l'on va
utiliser des minuscules mais vu que
l'étoile c'est au grand ah ben on va
commencer à bille minuscule fake
première planète que tu trouves autour
de kepler 458 mais tu l'appelles 458 b
minuscule qui s'en trouve une autre
s'appelle c'est des pilotes pour
l'instant on n'est pas rendus à épuiser
les lettres de notre alphanim comme pour
les ouragans falloir qu'on me le trouver
pour saab était dans un système de riz
on n'a pas encore trouvé france et
jusqu'à ils allaient système qu'elle
plus d'exoplanètes confirmé ces
questions je suis au début on parlait de
la question dans le fond le en fait la
question que je te demandais c'était ce
que tu penses que de notre vivant on va
de la vie qu'est ce que tu réponds aux
gens qui sont persuadés mettons qu'on
l'a déjà fait ce contact eu le temps que
les gens qui veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui s'intéressent à se doter des
phénomènes paranormaux de deux visions
de lipides sopi plis gens qui sont
vraiment qui se penche là-dessus c'est
tellement d'évidence il ya tellement
beaucoup d'occasions parce qu'on voit
des trucs explicable peu je sais 10e
puis si on regarde les anciennes
civilisations comme les égyptiens est
impossible ça a pris de l'aide
qu'est-ce que tu réponds à ces gens qui
sont persuadés qu'ils sont parmi nous
au petit matin ben moi je pense que
quand quelqu'un est convaincu quelque
chose ça sert pas grand chose de
commencer à le bombarder en disant c'est
pas vrai ce que tu penses tu essaies
pour ceux-là le consensus scientifique
même mais entre toi et moi
vous et moi c'est pas le consensus
scientifique fait que prend que si je
rencontrais quelqu'un qui était
convaincu de ce jeu j'en serai avec pour
avoir plus d'informations parce que
façon moi je suis bien curieusement vie
fait que je serais intéressé de savoir
c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui lui permet
d'être convaincus de ce jeu ça m'est
déjà arrivé dans une classe de 5e à nil
qui a toute la classe était vraiment
convaincu jean que les reptiliens était
parmi nous guy en creusant un peu
dépassé mon choc initial parce que
j'allais leur parler d'exoplanètes mais
j'ai changé j'ai changé de programme
parce que j'étais copain on a quelque
chose qui doit être adressée ici puis
bin là sur ces cueilli écoutait tout des
vidéos youtube qui se partageaient un
autre puits avait commis de grosse cage
de résonance et on parle des fois de
l'effet des médias sociaux mais dans
cette classe le pays était rendu
plusieurs à penser que c'est tout à fait
plausible que les certains leaders de ce
monde soit des extraterrestres bon le
besoin de parler du fait que je trouve
ça très très improbable
on a parlé du duo d'aider à quel point
c'est difficile c'est de créer une vie
de créer une vie intelligente de voyager
parmi les étoiles fectivement je pense
vraiment pas que ça soit plausible que
qui est une civilisation qui soit déjà
parmi nous et qui s'assure que c'est pas
tout le monde qui suit on dirait que
dans ma tête j'imaginerais plus haut à
la independence day and see comme papon
et l'autre et puis pourquoi sont là
parce que j'essaie d'imaginer les
motivations m'étais entre colonies comme
en rendant en as trop sociologie le jeu
des gones qui viendraient ici c'est sûr
que si on fait de l'extrapolation ont
peut-être qu'ils viendraient ici pour
nos ressources pour ses panneaux
connaissance je sais pas mais moi
premièrement autres comme j'aurais
savoir ils sont du pacifique le type est
ce que c'est si la chambre ce qu'on
pourrait bon et propre et mon équipe on
y verrait je sais pour l'instant mais ça
c'est vraiment mes croyances
personnelles même somme qu'ils auraient
plus de chances que ce soit comme ça que
juste de 17 personnes d après ce qu est
chiche
ils ont su y dessus eu un événement qui
a fait douter la communauté scientifique
rien du plan haïti ça a été ça a été
étudié des tonnes et des tonnes de fois
le tri ne serait-ce que tout les ovnis
le l'armée américaine près de huy est
bien intéressé à savoir c'est quoi les
éoliennes study éoliennes c'est comme
dans le temps de souffler et eliane
ressources et des films d'autres
planètes donc ça a été fouillé le ca a
été recherché de fond en comble qui le
fait est que ya plein de choses qui sont
comme mystérieuse incroyable
inhabituelle dans l'univers qui ne
nécessite pas d'extraterrestres pour
être expliquée donc quand tu te penches
sur les codes ont par exemple devenir
des objets volants qui sont non
identifié était capable d identifier
dans la très grande majorité des cas
puis c'est pas parce que t'es pas
capable de toute identification dire
qu'il ya des extra tpiy comme c'est pas
c'est quand on parlait du rasoir de
calmes tantôt le thé là ce n'est pas la
solution la plus simple que ce soit une
autorisation qui s'intéresse que soit
l'homme qui essaient de se cacher petit
je lisais dernièrement qu'ils étaient et
on résout pas non plus toutes les
meurtres le on n'a pas le taux de
résolution de toutes les mystères dans
notre qui on est correcte avec ça mais
on dirait que des fois quand il ya des
gens veulent croire mais ils voient ce
qu'ils veulent croire pineau si le tout
fait tout le monde on on a ces billets
le t on veut quand on veut revoir
quelque chose on le voit appuie
d'ailleurs on doit se battre se battre
conçu en sciences parce que c'est par
exemple des exemples c'est plus le fun
d'annoncer que je trouve une exoplanète
quand on n'a pas trouvé
moi j'ai fait j'ai fait mon doctorat
puis on a eu la chance de trouver une
exoplanète en place qu'on entend
n'attendez pas pantoute qui a appris à
monter comme abc nice peut-être quand
notre plein d'eau de même fait quand
même une autre étudiante qui
travaillaient sur le même projet moi
frédéric baron qui travaillent avec moi
encore et elle alla alors ne cherchez
aussi fait est là on n'a pas trouvé
l'idée a fait exactement
pas parce que c'est pas moins
intéressant le sien dit même et c'est ça
mais on ne sait bien lui comme humain
qui convolent on veut y croire on veut
découvrir l'effectif c'est ça je pense
qui intervient beaucoup de ces dans ses
scénarios le rapid et toutes les
affaires de m
ancient aliens series on a fait mais ça
me fâche quand même vraiment beaucoup
cette j'écoutais déboule au japon peu la
promotion céder le whip it ils font
d'une manière un peu malade sa c'est ce
qui passe sur netflix fait qu'il imagine
que c'est sur youtube lancé sur youtube
les ja pas juste c'est ça il ya juste
pas d'édition c'est pas des choses qui
aurait à passer dans les médias
traditionnels parce que c'est pas
honnête intellectuellement d'armagnac
ils font c il te bombarde informations
qui sont comme un peu déconnecté titre
un peu tout le phénomène de 'fait news
l'été ça devient un peu genre c'est plus
c'est pas comme souhaité qu'on travaille
le pis c'est pas comme ça que l'humanité
a fait des grands progrès puis aureus à
apprendre tout ce qu'on a appris puis on
en a appris des choses copie honnêtement
si tu en as des preuves le tai chi à
quelque chose d'inexpliqué que ça fait
vraiment du sens qu'ils soient
expliquées par la liste reste ahmed
moualek la communauté scientifique est
très intéressé leurs pieds dans le passé
récent en estrie en astrophysique en ont
eu plein de comm ca abandonné il y avait
une étoile qu'on observait qui variaient
d'une manière vraiment étrange fait pas
du tout est expliqué maintenant par une
planète qui passe devant
sa luminosité a diminué de genre 20%
alors lui même les plus grosses planètes
c'est comme un pour cent vingt
quotidiens au lieu de négoce que oui
c'est ça il y en a dans la communauté
qui ont conquis on dit ça pis à l'a été
vérifiés ils y ont été observés ci avait
me tombe la cie avec la chaleur qui
sortait de la route et si c'était son
rayonnement était telle qu'on pourrait
seule attente c était une méga structure
on a vérifié ça nous intéresse de savoir
nous il est et s'il ya des civilisations
extraterrestres mais c'est quand tu
m'amènes des affaires mais quelqu'un
amène des affaires de henson eliane que
mais ça tout était quasiment un parole
des blasons ça devient un peu lourde
séquence avait tout le temps ça revient
total c'est comme c'est que me parle à
un mur un peu le sur l'échelle expliqué
que ça se fait pas aux bleus la personne
comme moi mais moi je crois mais qui
tombe dans les croyances et religieuses
que scientifique le mois et c'est ce
qu'ils foutent et je pense que c'est
important support important de respecter
la diversité croyances tout ce qui est
importante je pense que ça a été un peu
beaucoup trop et vous a été traitée
d'une manière un peu hautaine par les
scientifiques
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la communauté
scientifique qui s'est diversifié qui
les jeunes pim pim mbh les plus vieux
qui ont qui réalise à quel point que
jusqu'à maintenant le y avait beaucoup
de la science qui était faite par des
hommes blancs lutic fait qu'est-ce que
ça t'amène comme viasat en amène un
paquet parce que quand tu obtiens quand
une certaine homogénéité bientôt pas une
diversité de points de vue une diversité
d'idées
donc on se rend compte à quel point
c'est important d'avoir une grande
diversité puis d'être plus inclusif dans
nos pratiques qui je pense que ça passe
aussi par paraître plus inclusif juste
dans notre façon de parler effective
mois quand les études le ya dix ans on
aurait parlé je te reparler de venir
puis gérer a adopté ce point de vue le
qui commence à céder des niaiseries
c'est vraiment pas sérieux
des fois quand on parle d'astrologie la
télé sauf que cissé a bougé depuis
mais maintenant j'avoue que je commence
assez juste c'est pas mon chantier si
toi ça t'amuse de lire ton astrologie
pikit se trouvent ceux ci ça t'aide à
organiser des idées dans ton dans ton
monde est parfait mais ça c'est pas de
l'astrophysique le toxico notre vision
objective du monde tels que construite
par la méthode scientifique c'est
important je pense d'eux quand même
séparés mais je trouve ça d'un corps est
que les deux mondes se parlent que
met-on moi-même choix capable de
je sais pas tout seul jeu il y en a qui
disent par exemple la lune c'est super
important pour ça va affecter genre le
stick menstruel les femmes mettons au
barça sa cause de cette possible de
montrer scientifiquement que l'effet de
marie dans ton corps à la pleine lune
deuil est totalement négligeable
c'est pas ça qui fait ça mais j'ai quand
même capable de reconnaître dans ma vie
que ben est mon cycle menstruel
unifrance qui jouit bic est ce que je
fais est le fait que c'est sans doute
rejeter complètement
c'est ça c'est pas quelque chose que
j'aurais dû garder de parler il ya dix
ans parce que j'étais dans un mode où
genre oh mon dieu je suis une femme mais
je devrai comme pas être là donc je
devrais pas être en train de parler de
ça et je trouve ça l'fun d'amener un peu
d'humanité dans la science parce qu'on
peut tout grandir de ces conversations
l'a écrit mme quirion qui disait que lui
quitté le scientifique en chef c'est lui
dans le fond unsa port par rapport à la
science était de de laisser des gens
derrière type je pense qu'en ce moment
avec la cuve vide on l'a bien vu thi
l'espèce de de clivage entre la science
la méthode scientifique puis les espèces
de croyances qui se crée un peu à
l'inter moi je pense qu'effectivement
n'ayant en ouvrant cette discussion le
tout le monde ensemble mais on veut plus
être capable d'éviter justement les
dérapages comme les théories du complot
sur un million d'affaires démocratise la
pensée scientifique a connaissance
maîtrisée un livre récemment qui a été
écrit par un chercheur français que je
n'aimerais pas son nom cité lui il
faisait de la vulgarisation scientifique
mais c'est la manière qui fait tout
était désagréable c'est quand ouvrez le
livre c'était désagréable oui allez
apprendre des choses parce que c'est un
bon vulgarisateur
mais son attitude était un support qui
défendons condescendante si c'est
vraiment comme et moi je suis tellement
gentil de venir expliquer des choses moi
mon point de vue c'est vraiment parce
que moi je comme immersif mais évitez
jazz avec moi aussi qui a plein de
choses pour lesquelles je suis aussi
intéressé par votre opinion m'a fait
souffrir tout le schloss intéressés par
votre opinion vous êtes intéressé par ce
que j'ai à vous apporter je pense que
c'est cette discussion le qu'on a besoin
de faire nos besoins de ramener les
scientifiques et dans le monde
oui c'est le fun patience mais comme tu
es tu capable de l'expliquer à
t'attendre la neige parce que sinon ça
sert à quoi
doré c'est super cool tout ce que tu as
appris mais mais personne ne sont pas
danger un triste pour ce mois en fait
présente pas j'en fais pas de la
recherche scientifique je fais je fais
de la communication pour l'éducation
scientifique c'est super important pour
moi et pour moi c'est comme le que c'est
là que ça va pouvoir changer notre sujet
des grandes voix option métiers qu'ils
avaient fois un peu amélioré notre monde
si tout le monde sait que ça leur
appartient la science que la discussion
est ouverte que les scientifiques les
regarde pas de europe en tout parce
qu'ils y ont autant apporter aux
scientifiques les scientifiques ont là
on va leur apporter
c'est juste des expertises différente
puisque tout le monde est capable de
s'intéresser à ceux construits sur notre
manque peut-être pas tout comprendre
mais moi non plus je comprends pas tout
le vraiment pas le j'ai passé tout mon
bac à me gratter la tête de m'arracher
les cheveux georges je comprends les
boules c'est vraiment il ya des choses
sont super compliqué les choses qu'on
comprend pas encore puis c'est bien
correct
c'est incorrect pour juger de tout
comprendre pour apprécier l'univers
c'est un excellent mot de la fin tout à
fait sûr ce merci beaucoup ça se fait à
l'intérieur c'est vraiment et merci
encore de m'avoir invité ce afin de
rappeler hier